THE PUBLIC WHO ARE WATCHING THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER. IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IT
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS NONE
OF OUR MEMBERS WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY.
IN THE SENATE CHAMBER WITH ME
ARE SENATORS CORTESEDOLLY
REQUIRE OCHO BOTH PAM AND
GLAZER. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE OVERS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT
NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER
IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE
ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT SEVEN SIX.
EIGHT NINE FOUR ONE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME AND PLEASE WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. WHAT YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
UNNEEDED AND YOU'RE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HIRING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IT IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE. OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES. CAN BE HEARD. WE HAVE
EIGHT BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
SB SIX NINETY TWO AUTHORED BY
SENATOR CORTESE HAS BEEN PULLED
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
FOR BILLS ARE ON CONSENT. THE
BILLS ON CONSENT. SB TWO FIFTY
FOUR. SB FIVE THIRTY TWO. SB
THREE NINETY THREE. SB FOUR
HUNDRED. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS.
WHAT'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LEYVA HERE LEYVA HERE UNTIL
ABOVE. A CHOI BOGUE HERE
COURTESY CORTEZ A HERE SALLY
KELLY HERE GLAZER. GLAZER HERE
MCGUIRE PAN PAN HERE. THE
CONSULTANT NOTES A QUORUM HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED LET'S HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR. I THINK
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SENATOR HER
TADO. I DO NOT SEE HER. WE ALSO
HAVE SENATOR RUBIO AND SENATOR
WIENER SO IF ANY THREE OF THOSE
AUTHORS. ARE HERE IN THE
BUILDING PLEASE COME TO THE
SENATE CHAMBER SO THAT YOU CAN
PRESENT YOUR BILL. IN THE
MEANTIME. WHAT'S VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR TO HAVE A
MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SO MOVED THANK YOU
SENATOR PAM THE MOTION TO. MOVE
THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
MADE BY SENATOR PAM BETTER
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CONSENT LEYVA. HI LEYVA HI
PHOTO ABOVE RIGHT THE TROUBLE
BOGUE I PROTESTED BY PROTESTS
THE AYE DALY. HI KELLY I GLAZER
AYE GLAZER HI MCGUIRE CAN I PAN
AYE WE WILL LEAVE THE ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO VOTE WE
ARE NOW JUST WAITING FOR AN
AUTHOR.
MEMBERS OF THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE ON
TIME AND PROMPTLY WE ARE
WAITING FOR ALL ONE OF OUR
THREE AUTHORS THAT WE HAVE
PRESENTING NONE OF THEM ARE
HERE YET SIMON A RECESS THE
COMMITTEE FOR FIFTEEN MINUTES.
IT IS NINE TWENTY TWO LET'S BE
BACK AT WHAT IS AT NINE THIRTY
SEVEN OKAY SO MAYBE GET A CUP
OF COFFEE OR SOMETHING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL END OUR
RECESS AND I BELIEVE THAT OUR
FIRST AUTHORS SENATORS RICARDO
IS HERE. SO SENATOR ALREADY
KNOW YOU'RE HERE SOMEWHERE
BECAUSE I SAW YOU PLEASE. COME
TO THE SENATE CHAMBER TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL SB.
THREE
SIXTY SEVEN. MEMBERS IS SB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
HER TADO SENATOR PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU ALL
STAR BASICALLY COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OFFERED ON PAGE
THREE OF THE ANALYSIS- TODAY
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB THREE
SIX SEVEN TO CAMPUS APPEARED
SAFETY ACT. SB THREE SIX SEVEN.
SIX TO REDUCE OPIOID RELATED
OVERDOSE DEATHS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES. THIS BILL
REQUIRES CS USING CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND ALSO
REQUEST UC REGENTS TO MAINTAIN
NASAL SPRAY DOSAGES NALOXONE.
THE OPIOID REVERSAL DRUG AT ON
CAMPUS HEALTH CENTERS AND ALSO
PROVIDE EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES
ON OVERDOSE PREVENTION DURING
CAMPUS ORIENTATIONS. THE CAMPUS
APPEARED SAFETY ACT AS A
NECESSARY INTERVENTION THAT
INCREASES ACCESS ACCESS TO
OPIOID REVERSAL MEDICATION ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND PROVIDES
OVERDOSE PREVENTION TRAINING TO
THOSE WHO NEED IT MOST. HERE TO
TESTIFY I HAVE JESSE HAYNER.
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER COURTED FOR
THE YOUNG PEOPLE IN RECOVERY.
AND GRETCHEN BERMAN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR AND CO FOUNDER OF A
NEW PATH. GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THOSE
WANTING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
TO THE CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE
CHAIRS MAY IS A TWO TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL
PREPARE PERMITTED AN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF TIME TO BE DETERMINED
BY THE CHAIR WE DO TWO MINUTES
OF FOR SUPPORT IN TWO MINUTES
FOR OPPOSITION SO WE WILL NOW
GO TO YOUR FIRST LEAD SUPPORT-
WHICH IS JESSE HANNER JESSE ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YES MA'AM.
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU
OPPOSITE FORMALLY BEGIN BY
SAYING THAT THE PERSONAL LONG
TERM RECOVERY WAS DOWN-
BATTLEMENTED HABITATION WHAT
FUTURE YEARS ALMOST AS I'M
ALMOST A SHARE WITH YOU TODAY
ON BEHALF OF MY AGENCY ON
PEOPLE RECOVERING THIS
COMMITTEE I DON'T HAVE THE TIME
THAT ENSURE THE SUCCESS STORIES
I WITNESSED FIRST HAND. WITH
OTHER SUBSIDIARIES OVERDOSE
INCLUDING MYSELF THERE TOO MANY
STORIES TO TELL SO MANY LIES
IMPACTED OTHERS MAY DECIDE WHAT
TO USE ALL OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE.
OFF BUT THEY WITH THE WRONG.
THOSE ARE NOT MEMBERS OF THE
SITE WANTS HELP ON THE VERGE OF
DEATH. EACH ONE STANDARD GRANT
TIME WERE CABLE APPLY. AND
ALLIES ARE NOT ONLY SAFE BUT-
WORKING WITH ADULTS AND I KNOW
ACTORS CURRENT USING- OPIOIDS
AND TO MAKE. A SCHOOL WORK. AS
I STATED I WORK FOR PEOPLE TO
CARRY NATIONAL. OF SERVICES OR
LIKE. HI MY LONGER THE ONLY IN
STOCK. AND THAT WILL PUT FULLY.
HOUSE CALL JUDGING YOU AN ADULT.
I SEE EVERY THEN I OF WORK FOR
YOU YOU DON'T PEOPLE WILL TO NO
OVER PREVENT MEASURES OF SITES.
WHAT ALSO FORCE. ONE THE BILL
BILL MOST. ARE SOME HAVE NEVER
BEEN AFFECT BY THE- DIRECTLY.
EVERYONE KNOWS SOMEONE WHO IS
STRUGGLING CAN ANYONE CAN BE AN
ALLY. I DON'T KNOW WITH SB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN COLLEGES
ACROSS THE STATE COULD BECOME
THE ALLIES. ASSEMBLY STUDENTS
WILL DEFINITELY NEED IN ORDER
TO ACHIEVE SUCCESS AND LONG
TERM RECOVERY. DAHLE
DEMONSTRATION BUT THE STUDENTS
THEMSELVES YOUR SUPPORT AND
KNOWLEDGE OF ACCESS. ONLY FOR
THEMSELVES BUT FOR THEIR FELLOW
STUDENTS PEERS AND NEIGHBORS.
WITH SIMPLE TRAINING ANYONE AND
THAT ARE NOT CANON ANYONE CAN
SAVE A LIFE. THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
PROVIDE EASY ACCESS VIDEO
TRAINING UPON INTAKE. AND
ORIENTATION OF THE STUDENTS
EASY ACCESS. TRAINS RARELY
AVAILABLE. AND ARCANUM YOU.
CAMPUSES AND WILL SAVE A LOT.
IN LET ME SAY. MY WHICH IS NOT
TO BE HERE TO. I WISH THIS
WASN'T SO ALL THE DEPUTY MAKE
IT. AS A AFFECT CERTAIN EMMA.
THIS USED THE REASON PEOPLE.
DID NOT DISCRIMINATE LIKE COLD
PLAN STATUS. IS HERE WHAT WE
WANT TO BE OR NOT. ANYONE CAN
BE A- BUT ALL CAN ALLIES. I
KNOW FIRST HOW. AND THE BENEFIT
OF OVERDOSE PREVENTION TOOL IN
OUR KIT. THE REAL TRAGEDY NOT
BE TO SOMEONE OVERDOSED A
COLLEGE. YEAH MAKING OTHER NEWS.
THE REAL TRAGEDY IN GOOD
PREVENTED IT. PLEASE ALLIES
WITH US THIS MOVEMENT. TO ALLOW
THE PREVENTION MEASURES. FOR
THESE REASONS WE AT THE SUPPORT
AS THREE SIX SEVEN YOU SO MUCH.
THE YOU MISTER HAYNER. I
BELIEVE WE ALSO HAVE A- BERGMAN
THE LINE GRETCHEN. YOU'RE THE
PLEASE. YES HI- I'M I'M- BERG
THEN I'M THE OF TWO SONS HE
STRUCK FOR DECADES TO HELP YOUR
ADDICTION. AND TO THE FOURTEEN
I TEND TO FOR THE BILL AND CAL.
THAT FOR. LIKE MY TO DISTRIBUTE.
NOT A LOT OF FUN. WE KNOW THAT
PARENTS ARE THE FIRST FIRST
STREET. SO I THOUGHT IT WAS MY
RIGHT RESPONSIBLE TO HAVE
NALOXONE AND MY TECHNICIAN
CAPITAL. FUND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF A NEW PATH YOUR
INTRODUCTION TREATMENT FEELING.
A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT
WORKS TO REDUCE THE STIGMA
ASSOCIATED WITH DRUG USE AND
ADDICTION. WE ADVOCATE FOR
THERAPEUTIC RATHER THAN
PUNITIVE DRUG POLICIES. AND WE
PROMOTE HARM REDUCTION
STRATEGY. DRUG USE IS HAPPENING
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES SO STUDENTS
AND FACULTY SHOULD BE PREPARED
TO STABILIZE THE FRIEND. YOUNG
COLLEGE AGE ADULTS ARE AT HIGH
RISK OF OVERDOSE DEATHS. SINCE
THE PANDEMIC BEGAN OVERDOSE
DEATHS HAVE RISEN BY. 13%
UNITED STATES. SINCE WE BEGAN
OVER FOR THE TRAINING ARE CAN.
THANK CAN WE'VE TRAINED OVER
TWO SEVENTY HUNDRED PEOPLE HAVE
A THOUSAND SEVEN AGAIN FIFTY
SIX LIVES RECORDED STRAIGHT ARE
PRO. WE RELY ON A REGULAR
SUPPLY OF NOT KNOWING ON. EIGHT
C. S. AS WELL A TEAM. MY
SENATORS SURVIVE OF ANOTHER AND
BOTH OF MY CENTER AMONG TERM
MAKE. WORKING AS OUT CAL OF ONE
COULD NOT CAN. SB THREE SO
WHICH THAT ALL COLLEGE HAVE NO
ON THE STORAGE ON CAMP HEALTH
THE FILM. WE HAVE TO. NOT CAN
TO SEVERAL NURSES THE BEST. AND
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD EXPAND
OUR TO. AND FACULTY IN ANY WAY
THAT WE- SEND MAKE MORE TO GO
NOW ON AND THAT WHY AT THE AND-
BETTER THAN HAVING TO DEAL
EMOTIONAL TRAGIC AND
UNNECESSARY LAW. IT EASIER. I
AM READERS. BEST THREE SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
BERGMAN MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
HERE IN THE GALLERY. SCENE NO
ONE WE WILL MOVE TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE IF THERE'S ANYONE THERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY SEEN
NO ONE. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR
WITNESSES TESTIFYING VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR ARE YOU THERE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE PLAGUE IN THE OTTOMAN.
YOU'RE GOOD GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL TAKE
CARE AND THANK YOU OFFLINE AND
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND LET YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE.
ZERO NOW. AND LIMóN MADAM
CHAIR WE LOOK LIKE WE HAVE TWO
PEOPLE QUEUING UP NOW THANK YOU.
YOUR COMMANDER. THANK YOU AYE
NUMBER FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AUDIBLE CHAIR MEMBERS
SHERRY DAILY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. THE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY TWO THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SH GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RON
RAPP ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. BETTER COMMENTED
HERE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE DID
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MATAMATA WRITER MEMBERS WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE SAME PROCESS
FOR OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED AND
WE'LL SEE HERE IN THE GALLERY
SCENE NO ONE. THING NO ONE IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE MADAM MODERATOR
DO WE HAVE ANYONE ON THE LINE
THAT WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE SIXTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN. PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR ONLINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
SIXTY SEVEN. FIVE ONE ZERO NOW.
IN AT THIS TIME AND I'M SURE WE
HAVE NO ONE SHOWING UP THINK
ABOUT A MODERATOR WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
DO WE HAVE ANYDISCUSSION OR
DEBATE OR ANY QUESTIONS ON THAT
YES SENATOR DOLLY. THE MANAGER
I JUST RISE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND MOVE IT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER DOLLY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE. US SENATOR HER TOTAL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTE
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR DOLLY MAN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IDM NUMBER THREE SB THREE SIXTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH LEYVA HI LEYVA HI PHOTO
ABOVE. A CHOI BOGUE HI PARTISI
HAS THE HI DALY GUARD DALY AYE
GLAZER ON IN THE MEDIA. HI
MCGUIRE. PAN PAN HI THINK YOU
WILL KEEP THAT BILL ON ON CALL
FOR MEMBERS WHO ARE NOT HERE TO
VOTE WE'RE NOW MOVING TO
SENATOR RUBIO CENTER RUBIO YOU
HAVE TO BILLS SB SEVENTY AND SB
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO BEGIN WITH SB SEVENTY.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR GOOD MORNING. OKAY IT'S A
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
I'M PROUD TO PRESENT SB SEVENTY
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THAT IS PART OF
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
BILL PACKAGE THAT MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE INTRODUCED
EARLIER THIS YEAR THIS BILL
WILL ENSURE THAT CHILDREN
RECEIVE CRITICAL INSTRUCTION
THE EARLIEST YEARS OF LEARNING
SPECIFICALLY SB SEVENTY WILL
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO COMPLETE
ONE YEAR OF KINDERGARTEN BEFORE
ENTERING THE FIRST GRADE. AS AN
EDUCATOR FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS I
HAVE PERSONALLY WITNESS HOWARD
EDUCATION CAN BE SUCH A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON STUDENTS
ACADEMIC SAYS FIX US UP ALSO
SEE HOW DETRIMENTAL IT COULD BE
TWO CHILDREN THAT HAVEN'T
ATTENDED SCHOOL. YOU CAN
INSTANTLY DISTINGUISHED SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT DID BENEFIT FROM
IT. BY WAY OF EXAMPLE AS A
TEACHER I'VE WITNESSED A CHILD
SITTING IN A CLASSROOM. HOLDING
A PENCIL TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT TO DO WITH IT HOLDING A
BOOK UPSIDE DOWN PLAYING WITH
EVERYTHING IN SIGHT. AND BEING
SOMEONE FOCUS BECAUSE THEY'VE
NEVER BEEN IN A SCHOOL SETTING.
ON THE CONTRARY WE HAVE
STUDENTS SITTING NEXT TO THEM
THAT. ARE READING AT A SECOND
GRADE LEVEL WRITING FULL
SENTENCES. READY FOCUS BECAUSE
THEY FELT THAT SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT EXPERIENCE. AND THE
DISPARITIES THAT WE WITNESS IN
OUR STUDENTS THEY'RE NOT ONLY
ACADEMIC IMMEASURABLE. BUT YOU
COULD ALSO PHYSICALLY AND
VISIBLY SEE. AS IT PERTAINS TO
STUDENTS CONFIDENCE AND
PARTICIPATION IN THE CLASSROOM.
THE COSBY NINETY PANDEMIC HAS
GREATLY AFFECTED ALL OF OUR
LIVES AMONG THOSE IMPACTED THE
MOST. HAVE BEEN OUR STUDENTS.
AND NOW MORE THAN EVER WE MUST
SUPPORT OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS
TO ENSURE THAT THEY RECEIVE THE
CRTICAL INSTRUCTION EARLY ON.
SO THAT THEY ARE SOCIALLY AND
ACADEMICALLY PREPARED FOR A
LIFETIME OF SUCCESS. STUDENTS
WHO DO NOT ATTEND KINDERGARTEN
ARE HAVING DIFFICULTY IN FIRST
GRADE. AND BECAUSE OF THAT OUR
TEACHERS AND PARENTS AS WELL.
THE TEACHERS ARE SPENDING MORE
TIME TRYING TO TEACH THEM THE
FOUNDATIONAL MATERIALS AND
SKILLS THAT THEIR PEERS HAVE
ALREADY MASTERED IN
KINDERGARTEN. ADDITIONALLY OUR
TEACHERS ARE STRUGGLING JUST TO
FIND WAYS TO SUPPORT THOSE
STUDENTS AND CONFINING-
CHALLENGING TRYING TO CATCH
THEM UP. WHEN THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
TO SCHOOL WE MUST INVEST IN
EARLY EDUCATION TO HELP OLDER
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS SO OUR
STUDENTS CONTINUE TO LEARN AT
GRADE LEVEL STANDARDS AND DON'T
FALL FURTHER BEHIND WHICH
CAUSES A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN
LATER YEARS. I ALSO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE WHY THIS BILL IS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT AND URGENT NOW.
ALSO STATE WE ARE SEEING A
LARGE DROP IN SCHOOL
ENROLLMENT. THE PANDEMIC HAS
LED TO A RECORD ONE YEAR
ENROLLMENT DROP OF ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA'S KATE
THROUGH TWELVE PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
ACCORDING TO NEW STATE
PROJECTIONS. THIS DROP IS EVEN
MORE PREVALENT IN THE KARTING
KINDERGARTEN LEVEL. IN ROMAN AT
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS SIGNIFICANTLY
DECLINED THIS DOCUMENT ACADEMIC
YEAR. KINDERGARTEN ENROLLMENT
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ACADEMIC YEAR HAS
DROPPED BY 14% THAT'S A DECLINE
OF SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS.
ESPECIALLY IN THE SCHOOL SYSTEM
SLOW IS INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
AND THIS DECLINE IS ABOUT-
THREE TIMES AS LARGE AS IN
RECENT YEARS. SACRAMENTO CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT ALSO
SAW A DECLINE OF SEVENTEEN
POINT 6% OAKLAND UNIFIED A 9%
DECLINE ALONG BEACH UNIFIED A
10% DECLINE. NEXT YEAR
EDUCATORS WILL FEEL GREATER
VARIANCE OF SKILLS AMONG FIRST
GRADE STUDENTS AND IT IS
CRITICAL THAT OUR STUDENTS GET
A HEAD START. AND HAVE THE
BUILDING BLOCKS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. AND NOT FALL
FURTHER BEHIND AND WE'RE
CONSTANTLY TRYING TO PLAY THE
GAME OF CATCH UP WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANTLY- WORSE AS THEY GO
UP THE SCHOOL YEARS THE. GAP
ONLY GROWS EXPONENTIALLY- SO WE
TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FOR THESE
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE START AT
THE SAME LEVEL AS THEIR PEERS.
WE NEED TO GIVE EVERY CHILD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REACH THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL. AND WE TO THAT WITH
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND
REQUIRING KINDERGARTEN
ATTENDANCE. ON THE PHONE TODAY
MADAM CHAIR IF I MAY I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY WITNESS
ALISON JOSHI MODEL TELL READ.
SHE'S A CHIEF ACADEMIC OFFICER
OF THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND DR CHARLES
HENCHMEN SUPERINTENDENT OF WEST
COVINA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
REVERE. ARMENTA MODERATOR WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THE TO LEAD
WITNESSES STARTING WITH ALLISON
YOSHIMOTO TARIK IF SHE'S ON THE
LINE PLEASE Q. HELLO. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MANAGER
LEYVA AND MEMBERS OF THE MONEY
MY NAME IS ALEXANDRA SHIMO
TERRY THE CHIEF ACADEMIC
OFFICER FOR THE LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WE
ARE PLEASED TO SPONSOR SENATE
BILL SEVENTY. AB SHOW THAT 95%
OF STUDENTS CURRENTLY ATTEND
KINDERGARTEN. AND THAT 5% OF
OUR YOUNG SCHOLARS HE NOT HAVE
THAT OPPORTUNITY. AND THEY ARE
UNDER PREPARED FOR FIRST GRADE
SIX S. EXPECTING THEIR
HAPPINESS THEIR CONFIDENCE AND
THEIR IDENTITY FOR LIFE. KEVIN
GARNETT SHE HAD THE TIME TO
WITH PRIMARY TEST. COLLEGE THEM
LONG TERM EARNINGS IN THE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND A RECENT
STUDY FOUND THAT BLACK AND
HISPANIC STUDENTS. WHO ATTENDED.
STUFF 5% IN COLLEGE COMPLETION.
RELATIVES WHO ARE QUITE. I
GUESS IT JUST FIFTEEN OVER THE
YEARS THAT AFTER DISTRICTS
STUDENTS IT'S MUCH HIGHER THAN
AT THE GREAT FOR EXAMPLE IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR DISTRICT
REPORTED 25% OF KINDERGARTEN
THIS. PMR DAYS EACH SCHOOL YEAR.
WHAT IT HADN'T STUDIES
CORRELATE THAT DOLLARS TO ARE
CHRONICALLY ABSENT INCREASE
PLUNGING. AND FIRST GRADE R.
PIKES LESS LIKELY TO READ BY
THIRD GRADE. STUDENTS WHO
CANNOT READ BY GRADE ARE FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY THAN
PROFICIENT READERS TO DROP OUT
OF HIGH SCHOOL. SB SEVENTY IS
AN IMPORTANT ASPECT IN REDUCING
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM
AMELIORATING THE OPPORTUNITY
GAP ON GETTING OUR STUDENTS
EVERY POSSIBLE ADVANTAGE AND
EARLY LIFE. AND CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IS SB SEVENTY
CONTINUE TO GET DISTRICTS THAT
HONEY OVER OFFERING FULL DAY OR
PART DAY CANDOR OUR FAMILIES ON
HOW TO ME TO CONTINUE TO SELECT
A PRIVATE. SCHOOL OPTION.
SCHOOLS ARE AT THE CENTER OF
OUR COMMUNITY. SB SEVENTY FOR
KINDERGARTEN FOR ALL WILL
SUPPORT ALL STUDENTS WITH
WRAPAROUND SERVICES ACADEMIC
SUPPORT AS EARLY AS POSSIBLE.
REDIRECTING THE NEED FOR
EXPENSIVE INTERVENTION OVER
REPRESENTATION AND
MISREPRESENTATION AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION. AND CATCH A PLAN
AFTER STUDENTS HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO SUPPORT. SENATOR RUBIO
REFERRED THE FACT THE PENDANT.
FLUSH JANET I THOUGHT ROMAN FEE
CREEK THAT FIX THOUSAND
STUDENTS THIS YEAR A PART
PERCENT DECLINE. MASON HEALING
AND THE- POSTED I AND OUR
INCOMING GRADERS WHO BEST CAN A
GUARD WILL HAVE FIFTY THE TOTAL.
INCLUDING A SEVENTY PASSING
BASED PRO. SUPPORT EARLY
STUDENT SUCCESS FOR ALL. 9%
EVERYDAY THREE HELLO EDITION OF
I THIS IS PROUD TO BE A THIRD
OF. AND URGES I UNDERSTAND.
THANK YOU THANK HENRY. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE THE
WAS CLEANING UP BY GO THIS
HERE'S AND RUBIO AND AS SEVENTY
I WILL TELL YOU IT'S AS MANY
CHIU COME MY DESK I HAVEN'T
SEEN ONE THAT MAKES SUCH SENSE
AS MANDATORY KINDERGARTEN- YOU
KNOW DISCUSSING THE ISSUE OF
MANDATORY KINDERGARTEN SUPPORT
REMEMBER THAT TODAY'S
KINDERGARTEN ISN'T WHAT IT USED
TO BE- I'D ASK THE PANELISTS
THINK BACK- MAYBE YOU HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND
KINDERGARTEN. I REMEMBER THINGS
LIKE- FINGER PAINTING I
REMEMBER- PLAYTIME AND ONE OF
MY FAVORITE EVENTS WAS NAP
TIME- BUT IT'S NO LONGER- AT A
PRE ACADEMIC CREATES ITS
FOUNDATIONAL THE EVERY STUDENT
AND ACADEMIC SUCCESS THESE
SUBJECT MATTERS IDENTIFY
KNOWLEDGE CONCEPTS CONCEPTS
SKILLS AND YOU CAN BE ACQUIRED
IN KINDERGARTEN AS BUILDING
BLOCKS FOR THE FIRST. GRADE
KINDERGARTEN. IS A GALLON STATE
STANDARD AND STANDARDS DON'T GO
AWAY THEY ARE REQUIRED THEY
DON'T MATCH. APPEAR IN THE
FIRST GRADE. I ALSO WOULD
ACTUALLY- COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER
BONE HIGHER PROGRAM OF HEAD
START AND WHAT IT INTENT IS IT
IS IT SHOULDN'T HAVE GUESTS TO
PREPARE THEM FOR THEIR
SCHOOLING ACTIVITY IT GETS SO
MUCH CRAP AND SO MUCH TIME.
THAT IF YOU IF WE LOOK AT HAD
STARTED OBVIOUSLY NATURALLY IN
PROGRESSES IN THE KINDERGARTEN
INTO A CHILD'S EDUCATION. AS
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER STAFF-
ACADEMIC SUCCESS IS BASED SO
MUCH JUST ON THOSE EARLY YEARS
THE READING LEVEL OF A FOURTH
GRADE STUDENT CAN TELL YOU CAN
BE A PREDICTOR OF THEIR
ACADEMIC SUCCESS NOW CONSIDER
WITHOUT KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
LOSING 25% OF THAT PREP WORK
GOING INTO THE FOURTH GRADE. I
CAN TELL YOU AS AN EDUCATOR YOU
SPEND ENDLESS TIME AND DOLLARS
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE AT GRADE LEVEL BY
THE FOURTH GRADE BECAUSE WE.
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY'RE
NOT. I TELL YOU WHEN WE ARE T.
ARE. ABOUT DIFFERENCE. A
STUDENT DO IT CONNECT. AND WHY
TO- THE ACTOR. KINDA LOOKED AT
AS DUMB. LIKE WHY WE THAT
QUESTION. IT WAS SO ODD TO THEM
CAN I ASK YOU. TO INCLUDE YOUR
OVER YOUR TO ME. OH MY GOSH I
GO FOR CERTAINLY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I TELL YOU THE WHAT
THE KNOW WE- MORE THAN A CAN
AGREE THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF. AND
WHILE WERE HELD RICK OUR- THOSE
CHILL WERE NOT HELD HIGH
REGARDING THEIR- SO WAS THE
PARKS DIST STRONG SUPPORT-
PROPOSITION- SENATE BILL
SEVENTY AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL GO TO MEMBERS IN SUPPORT
IN THE GALLERY SEEING NONE WE
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING THEN WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES. MADAME
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYONE
QUEUED UP IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTY COULD PRESS ONE ZERO.
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER. PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVENTY. COULD PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE ARE NOW. MADAM CHAIR
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE ABOUT ELEVEN
PEOPLE IN Q. VERY GOOD PLEASE
START WITH THE FIRST ONE
THOUSAND Q. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LINE NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ON A ROLL CHAIRED
MEMBERS THIS IS DR ELIZABETH
AMMON HEISER SUPERINTENDENT
ACCORDING TO VALUE TO HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF SENATOR RUBIO AND AT
LEAST SEVENTY AT THE START OF
EACH SCHOOL YEAR KINDERGARTEN
THANK YOU JUST JUST NAME AND
SUPPORT PLEASE THANK YOU JUST
NAME IN SUPPORT NEXT A- NEXT
PERSON PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LINE NUMBER THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HOW GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS COUNTY DOWN
OFTEN REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. BUT I NUMBER SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING IF THEY'RE A
LITTLE UPSET THAT YOU'RE
DIRECTOR FOR KEEPS CALIFORNIA
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND SB
SEVENTY. THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE DOWNLOAD
WITH A CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN COURT.
THANK YOU. WHY NUMBER ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
ACTUALLY FORTY OR BELOW WITH
CHILD THREE SIXTY AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YES SB
SEVEN. THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MARIA
JOHNSON DIRECTOR OF STUDENT
SERVICES CHILD WELFARE AND
ATTENDANCE SHAHROKH UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AN ADVOCATE FOR SENATE
BILL SEVENTY THREE THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DID DONNA HARD TO GET THERE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IN STRONG
STRONG SUPPORT SB SEVENTY.
THANK YOU. NUMBER SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DISTRICT MANAGER ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT ON BEHALF OF
COSTING ABOUT TWENTY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT SB SEVENTY.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR YEAH LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FRIEDMAN ENTRIES WITH
THE PRINTING OF THE JUDICIAL
SERVICES WITHIN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT OF WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MY NUMBER
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS DOCTOR TIFFANY REJECT
YOU BRING CANNOT EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES FOR THE GARBAGE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND GARBI. HAD STRONG
STRONG SUPPORT SB SEVENTY AND
WE ASKED FOR YOURS AS WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
PRIME NUMBER THIRTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS ALICE
KESSLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION WE THANK SENATOR
RUBIO FOR AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL AND ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER SEVENTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MARTHA
JERICHO'S IDES REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SEVENTY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION PUBLIC.
SIXTY PROFESSIONALS- INTO FOR
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND AT THIS TIME MEDICARE WE
HAVE NO ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR WE WILL NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION I DO KNOW THAT WE
HAVE- SOMEONE WHO CALLED IN
LATE FOR LEAD OPPOSITION MADAM
MODERATOR I'M LOOKING FOR A
NATHAN PIERCE. HOWEVER HE MAY
JUST BE QUEUED UP ON A REGULAR
LINE. ONE MOMENT. MISTER PETERS
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE
ON THE LINE WHEN THAN THEIR-IF
YOU'RE ON THE LINE THE PEERS.
ONE MOMENT IN CHAIR THANK YOU.
LEAVE FORMER BUSINESSES AND
LINE NUMBER TWELVE MR PEERS OF
THIS STORYLINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES THANK YOU NAY CAN. ON
BEHALF OF PRIVATE HOME
EDUCATORS CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
I'M SURE MEMBERS AND MR. YOU
HAVE TWO AND A HALF MINUTES
BECAUSE OUR ALL OUR SUPPORT
WENT OVER SO YOU WILL BE A OT
OF THE SAME AMOUNT OF TIME YOU
HAVE TWO AND A HALF MINUTES
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU. SB
SEVENTY AMEND THAT PORTION OF
THE CODE THAT GOVERNS THE
ENROLLMENT ELIGIBILITY OF A
STUDENT IN THE FIRST GRADE OF A
PUBLIC SCHOOL DUE TO THE
CONFUSION REGARDING THE
APPLICABILITY WE ARE REQUESTING
AN AMENDMENT TO CLARIFY THE
LANGUAGE WITH REGARD TO WHICH
SCHOOLS ARE IMPACTED BY THE
BILL. PLEASE ACCEPT OUR
AMENDMENT TO ADD THE WORDS IN A
PUBLIC SCHOOL TO THE KEY
PROVISION OF THE BILL TO
CLARIFY THIS POINT THE-
BACKSEAT IN THE COMEDIAN LSS-
WITH EXEMPLIFIED THE NEED FOR
CLARIFICATION ON THIS POINT-
APPROXIMATELY 95% OF PARENTS
ENROLL THEIR CHILDREN IN
KINDERGARTEN. BELIEVING THAT
THIS COURSE IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THEIR CHILD. PERSON
OF THE REMAINING PERCENTAGE ARE
ENGAGED IN SOME OTHER FORM OF
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION SOME
MORE FORMAL AND SOME LESS
FORMAL. THIS LEAVES A VERY
SMALL NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN WHOSE NEEDS REQUIRE
THEIR PARENTS TO INDIVIDUALLY
DESIGNED AND ADAPT THEIR
EDUCATIONAL TIMELINE UNIQUELY
TO THEM. THE PARENTS OR
GUARDIANS OF THESE INDIIDUALS
HAVE DETERMINED THAT IT IS NOT
IN THEIR BEST INTEREST TO
ENROLL THEM IN KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM BECAUSE OF
DISADVANTAGES THAT WOULD BE
SPECIFIC TO THAT TRIAL. IT IS
BEST TO NOT MANDATE
KINDERGARTEN AND ALLOW THESE
FEW CHILDREN TO THRIVE IN THEIR
OWN WAY UNTIL AGE SIX. THE
LEGISLATURE HAS GONE ON RECORD
IT KNOWLEDGE IN THAT THERE CAN
BE DISADVANTAGES. TO ENROLLING
SOME CHILDREN IN KINDERGARTEN
AT AGE FIVE IN THAT PARENTS
MUST BE ALLOWED TO CONSIDER
THESE DISADVANTAGES IN DECDING
WHETHER OR NOT TO ENROLL THEIR
CHILD. EDUCATION CODE SECTION
FOUR EIGHT ZERO ZERO ZERO B.
THE LEGISLATURE AWARE OF THE
DISADVANTAGES SPECIFIED THAT
THE PARENT OR GUARDIAN IS GIVEN
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
ADVANTAGES AND DISADVANTAGES.
OF ANY OTHER IN ANY OTHER
EXPLANATORY INFORMATION ABOUT
THE EFFECT OF THIS EARLY
ADMITTANCE. WE CANNOT DRAW A
LINE SAY WHEN ALL CHILDREN ARE
READY FOR SCHOOL WELL THIS BILL
DOES NOT DOES ALLOW PARENTS TO
CHOOSE TO DELAY THEIR CHILD'S
FORMAL EDUCATION. THERE WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY BE PRESSURED TO
IGNORE THOSE DISADVANTAGES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SO ADAMANTLY
REFERRED TO IN. SECTION FOUR
EIGHT ZERO ZERO ZERO WITH
RESPECT TO THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE CHILD AND TRYING TO A
CHILD'S PARENT OR GUARDIAN OF
THE SECTION. REQUIRES FOR IT
ADMITTANCE YOUNGER THAN AGE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS TO MAKE THEIR
OWN DETERMINATION TOGETHER WITH
PARENTS. AS WHICH CHILD BEST
PATH FOR INSTRUCTION IN NOT
REQUIRED KINDERGARTEN. FOR
PRIVATE SCHOOLS. THE GREENER TO
DINNER. ALL SHORT GAIN THANK
YOU. YOUR EX TIME THANK YOU FOR
MUCH MEMBERS WE WILL NOW GO
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWELVE ONE TWELVE SEEING NONE.
MADAM MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO IS IN OPPOSITION SB.
SEVENTY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN. AND THE OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK TO THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVENTY. PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
ONE MOMENT MANAGER LOOKS LIKE
WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE QUEUING UP.
THANK YOU AND FOR THOSE QUEUING
UP PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
MADAM CAIR LINE NUMBER
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK WHEN
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOMESCHOOL NETWORK AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SEVENTY
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
HEATHER MARTIN FROM
REPRESENTING CELEBRATION
EDUCATION AND WE OPPOSE AB
SEVENTY I MEAN SB THIRTY THANK
YOU. LET THIS TIME OUT I'M SURE
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU MADAM MODERATOR MEMBERS
WILL BRING IT BACK TO YOU AT
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CENTER
TROUBLED. I HAVE A COMMENT HERE
WE KNOW TESTING. TESTING YOU
SHOULD BE GOOD NOW OKAY- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY MADAM
CHAIR TO SPEAK THIS MORNING AS
A FORMER EDUCATOR AS A MOTHER
OF THREE CHILDREN I AM THE
FIRST AND FOREMOST TO SAY
EDUCATION IS A MUST FOR EVERY
CHILD AND DEVELOPMENTALLY IT'S
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I LEFT
THE CLASSROOM. AND DECIDED TO
STAY HOME AND- TEACH MY
CHILDREN VIA WHAT I CALL THE
PROFESSIONAL PARENT. I EIGHT.
I'D LOVE TO TEACH AID LOVED
BEING IN THE CLASSROOM BUT
BETWEEN DECIDING BETWEEN
TEACHING OTHER CHILDREN OR
TEACHING MY OWN I DECIDED TO
TEACH MY OWN AND THAT'S- IN
THAT CONTEXT IN WHICH I'M GOING
TO BE SPEAKING AND ASKING SOME
QUESTIONS- FIRST AND FOREMOST.
JUST A AB ONE TO ASK THE AUTHOR.
WHEN IT THE STATE MANDATES THAT
A CHILD. ATTEND SCHOOL BY A
CERTAIN AGE SAY FIRST GRADE.
AND UP TOWARD- ARE THERE
PENALTIES FOR PARENTS WHO OPTED
NOT TO ENROLL THEIR CHILD IN
SCHOOL. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION WELL THEY
WILL FOLLOW THE OF THE
TRADITIONAL ROUTE OF- HAVING
THE OPTION FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO USE OUR- TO ENCOURAGE
PARENTS TO ATTEND AND JUST LIKE
ON A REGULAR SCHOOL. DAY WOULD
WORK WITH THE PARENT TO ENSURE
THAT THEY HELP ON WITH THE
DEFICIENCIES IN TRYING TO GET
THEIR STUDENTS TO ATTEND CLASS.
BUT ARE THERE PENALTIES AGAINST
PARENTS OR CARETAKERS WHO ARE
CHOOSING NOT TO. ASK BUT THEIR
SCHOOL THEIR CHILDREN IN IN
PUBLIC SCHOOL. THERE WILL NOT
BE ACCEPTED INTO FIRST GRADE
UNLESS THEY HAVE THAT THAT- CAN
REGARDING YOUR BEFORE ENTERING
A PUBLIC SCHOOL. OKAY THE
REASON I ASK IS IF. WE ALL KNOW
DEVELOPMENTALLY CHILDREN VERY
QUITE DISTINCTLY BETWEEN BIRTH
AND FIVE YEARS THOSE ARE
INCREDIBLY- IMPACTFUL YEARS.
AND I AM COMPLETELY AWARE AND
COMPLETELY- ENDORSED THE NOTION
OF EDUCATION- IN THOSE FIVE
YEARS AS BEING PIVOTAL FOR AT
THE PROPER SUCCESS FOR KIDS
LATER ON BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE CHILD.
AND GIVING PARENTS THE OPTION
AND WHETHER OR NOT- FORMALES
KINDERGARTEN IS THE RIGHT PLACE
FOR THEIR FIVE YEAR OLD OR
VERSUS A DIFFERENT MODEL OF
SCHOOLING- THAT IS AVAILABLE TO
THEM. SO. MY CONCERN IS THAT IF
A PARENT DOES NOT FEEL THAT
THEIR CHILD IS- MATURITY
EMOTIONALLY PSYCHOLOGICALLY AND
PHYSICALLY TO ATTEND- V.
MANDATED TO ATTEND AT A SCHOOL
IN CALIFORNIA- WE ARE ONE
TAKING AWAY THE OPERATIVE OF
APPARENT MAKING THAT CHOICE AND
NUMBER TWO- I'M CONCERNED THAT
THE CHILD'S DEVELOPMENTAL-
LEVEL IS. IS NOT BEING
CONSIDERED IN THIS BILL- YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT. THIS WILL
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THIS
BILL DOES GIVE PARENTS OPTIONS.
THEY HAVE THE OPTION TO ENROLL
THE CHILD IN KINDERGARTEN BUT
THEY ALSO HAVE THE OPTION TO
TAKE THE HOME SCHOOL OPTION
THAT WE'D LIKE YOU DID FOR YOUR
OWN CHILDREN AND THEY HAVE THE
OPTION TO. ENTER A PRIVATE
SCHOOL AS WELL SO AS LONG AS
THERE IS SOME TYPE OF EDUCATION
PRIOR TO COMING INTO THE FIRST
GRADE THOSE ARE THE OPTIONS
PARENTS HOUSE SO IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY MANDATING THAT THEY
GO TO PBLIC SCHOOL. THEY'RE
GIVEN THE HOME SCHOOL OPTION AS
WELL. OKAY SO JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE YOU'RE NOT MANDATING SO
PARENTS OR CAREGIVERS WILL NOT
BE PENALIZED FOR NOT HAVING A
FORMAL. SCHOOL OPTION FOR THEIR
CHILDREN. WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
FOR MORE ON THE HOME SCHOOL
OPTION IT BEARS SOME GUIDELINES
FOR HOME SCHOOLING STILL YOU
WOULD HAVE TO PROVIDE PROOF TO
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT
THEY'VE ATTENDED AND PICK YOUR
PRIOR TO COMING TO FIRST GRADE-
IN A WAY OF AFFIDAVIT SEOUL.
FORMAL MEANS IT HAS TO BE SOME
KIND OF CURRICULUM THAT IS THAT
IS FORMAL YES OKAY- I'M IN AND
THAT'S THE OTHER THAT'S THE
OTHER CONCERN THAT I'M GONNA
HAVE TO BRING UP IS- THE CURE
HIM THERE ARE PHILOSOPHIES
WHERE THEY FEEL THAT CHILDREN
UNDER THE AGE OF FIVE TO HAVE
THE FREEDOM. TO NOT BEING A
FORMALIZED STRUCTURED
ENVIRONMENT THAT HAVE THE
FREEDOM TO LEARN DIFFERENT
SUBJECTS AND DIFFERENT MANNER
SO I AM I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED
ABOUT THAT THE END ON ON THAT
TO HAVE A FORM CURRICULUM FOR
KINDERGARTEN ALTHOUGH
PERSONALLY HE SAID I BELIEVE
STRONGLY IN EDUCATION I JUST
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT.
TAKING THE PARODIC OF APPARENT
MAKING A CHOICE BUT MANDATING
OR HAVING THE STATE TELEPRINTER
THIS IS WHEN WE THINK YOUR
CHILD SHOULD BELONG. IN A
FORMAL LADY AND- IN A FORMAL.
STRUCTURE CURING BAY. ON AGE
PROGRAM- THE THAT AND- BUT
THAT'S IT. THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU SENATOR AND TROUBLED
CAN I ADDRESS YES PLEASE YOU
KNOW I JACQUI WANNA- SHE YOUR
COMMENTS I JUST. REALLY I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SHARE THAT AT
THIS TIME APPROXIMATELY 90% OF
STUDENTS ALREADY ATTEND YEAH
AND SO WHEN WE SEE WHERE THOSE
GAPS ARE UNFORTUNATE ALWAYS
HAPPENS TO BE THOSE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY CENSUS. WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO CAPTURE THOSE PARENTS
THAT ARE NOT SOMEONE THAT WOULD
AUTOMATICALLY KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITH THEIR CHILDREN AT HOME AND
CELL ALL OF US HERE ON THIS
FLOOR. WHAT EASILY BE ABLE TO
EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN WE
UNDERSTAND THE SYSTEM WE
UNDERSTAND. YOU BASED ON OUR
FORMAL EDUCATION WHAT TO DO
WITH THEIR CHILDREN HOWEVER. I
CAN THERE IS A PORTION OF
CHILDREN THAT ARE STAYING HOME.
AND IF THE STATE DOESN'T
MANDATE IT IT ALMOST A SENSE A
MESSAGE TO THESE PARENTS THAT
IT'S NOT NECESSARY. AND I CAN
SPEAK FROM MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE IN THE CLASSROOM I
HEARD ONE OF THE SPEAKERS SAY
THAT HE ASKED A QUESTION TO ONE
OF HIS TEACHERS. WELL I CAN
ANSWER THAT AS WELL I TAUGHT
FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL I WAS THE TEACHER THAT
CAPTURED THE CHILDREN THAT HAD
GAPS IN THEIR EDUCATION. AND
MOST OFTEN IT WAS THOSE
CHILDREN THAT COME FROM LOW
INCOME HOMES WHO DIDN'T ATTEND
KINDERGARTEN THAT WERE
STRUGGLING. AND UNFORTUNATELY
THEY NEVER CAUGHT UP AND- FOR
ME THIS IS JUST AN IMPORTANT
STEP TO. SEND THE MESSAGE
NUMBER ONE THAT KINDERGARTEN IS
IMPORTANT AND TO HELP THOSE
PARENTS THAT DON'T TRULY
UNDERSTAND HOW VALUABLE
KINDERGARTEN IS THE TO LEARN
FOUNDATIONAL SKILLS AND THAT IS
THE BUILDING BLOCKS. TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. FROM KATIE THREE
THREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR DOLLARS SENATE BILL I'M
SORRY DID YOU WANT TO EXPAND ON
THAT YES PLEASE IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND SENATOR TROUBLED CENTER
REVIEW WITH THE MOST RESPECT I
DO NOT QUESTION AT ALL THE
INTENT OF THE PURPOSE OF- OF
WANTING TO HAVE. KINDERGARTEN
MANDATED I ABSOLUTELY
COMPLETELY BELIEVE IN THE VALUE
OF IT. IT'S JUST. TAKING AWAY
THE ACT. THAT PARENTAL CHOICE
ON THAT END AND THEN FOLLOWING
UP ON THAT YOU DID SAY. BY
CARRYING THE MESSAGE ON THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR CALIFORNIA.
TO HAVE KINDERGARTEN AS A- AS A
MANDATORY CLASS- WHAT'S- IN
THIS BILL WOULD YOU MIND
EXPLAINING WHAT THE WHAT.
EMPOWER ME DO YOU GIVE THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO FOLLOW WITH
THOSE PARENTS WHO DO YOU CHOOSE
NOT TO PUT THEIR CHILDREN IN IN
KINDERGARTEN. WELL EVERY AT WE
HEARD ABOUT THE SUPPORTERS IS
MOSTLY HILLS SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE. SUPPORTING THIS BILL-
BECAUSE THEY SEE JUST HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO WORK WITH
PARENTS AND THEIR CAREER YEARS
SELL- THAT THEY HAVE THE POWER
TO WORK WITH PARENTS LIKE AYE
SHORTER AYE FONG. PARENTS ARE
HAVING A DIFFICULT TIME SENDING
THEIR CHILDREN TO SCHOOL THEY
WORK WITH THEM AND YOU KNOW I
WAS ALSO IN CHARGE OF SARBAND
MY SCHOOL AND SO. WE DO GIVE
THEM MULTIPLE OPPORTUNITIES TO
A TWO CORRECT YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE THE ABSENTEEISM OR-
SOMETIMES THEY JUST DROP OUT
FOR WEEKS AND MONTHS AND SELL
THE ALWAYS WORK WITH PARENTS
THAT IS THE GOAL OF THE SCHOOLS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO ENSURE
THAT WE PROVIDE HELP TO
PARENTS. AND DO WHAT WE CAN TO
HELP THEM BE SUCCESSFUL. AND DO
WE NOT HAVE- RIGHT NOW AS IT
STANDS THE MOST COOL DISHES NOT
DO THAT ALREADY TO ENCOURAGE-
UNIVERSITY I'M JUST SPEAKING
FROM MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE ON
OUR SCHOOL BOARD- WHERE WE- ARE
WE EVEN OFFER TKA- CLASSES AND
ENCOURAGE OUR PARENTS AND OUR
FAMILIES AND PROMOTED LOCALLY.
WITHOUT BEING MANDATED WE JUST
FEEL THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO DO
THAT IN OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT WE
ARE AND WE- MARKET. THAT THAT
ENDEAVOR SO ARE WE SEEING THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE NOT DOING
THAT IN THESE LOW INCOME-
COMMUNITIES THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO. NO BECAUSE
KINDERGARTEN IS CURRENTLY NOT
MANDATED IT STARTS AT SIX YEARS
OLD SO THAT THEY CANNOT. YOU
KNOW HELP PARENTS BE SUCCESSFUL
IN BRINGING THEIR KIDS TO
SCHOOL BECAUSE- IT IS NOT
CURRENTLY MANDATORY. SALAS WE
MAC MAKE IT MANDATORY THEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN INTERVENE
AND OFFER SUPPORT TO THESE
PARENTS THAT ARE STRUGGLING. HI
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER CHOI
BOGUE CENTER DOLLY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- JUST QUESTION
AUTHORED BY SO LOOK WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. WHAT I
UNDERSTOOD ABOUT 10% OF THE
POPULATION IS 90% ARE ALREADY
DOING IT. SENATE 10% I HEARD
YOU SAY EARLIER ANOTHER
QUESTIONS WAS THAT. YOU CAN'T
ENTER KINDERGARTEN WITHOUT.
GOING THROUGH THIS PROCESS SO
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF SOMEBODY
JUST CHOSE NOT TO DO IT. AND
NOW THEIR CHILD IS THERE AT SIX
YEARS OLD AND HASN'T HAD THIS
COURSE. I THINK I BELIEVE YOU
STATED. THAT- I'M SORRY. IF
THEY COME TO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT I WAS ABOUT TO SAY US
IF THEY COME TO SCHOOL DISTRICT
YOU KNOW AND THEY HAVE NOT HAD
KINDERGARTEN THEY WILL BE
REQUIRED TO ATTEND KINDERGARTEN
AND YOU STATED YOU KNOW A CHILD
BEING SIX I BELIEVE RIGHT NOW
40% OF STUDENTS ARE SIX YEARS
OLD THAT INTER CANDOR SO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT ALREADY HAPPENS
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT IS
UNUSUAL FOR A SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO HAVE A- SIX YEAR OLD IN
KINDERGARTEN. SO WHAT THE
QUESTION I ASKED IS. IF THIS IS
GONNA BE MANDATORY AND IF AND
IF THEY DON'T DO THE HOMES PART
OF IT THEY DON'T DO. THEY DON'T
COMPLETE THE TASK SAY THEY JUST
pEXPERIENCE I GUESS I SHOULD SAY
WITH PARENTS WHO ARE SINGLE
PARENTS WHO ARE. NOT CONNECTED
TO IT THERE THERE'S THEY'RE NOT
CONNECTED TO THE SYSTEM I GUESS
I SHOULD SAY AND THEY MAY JUST
NOT DO IT AT ALL DOES NOT EVEN
KNOW ABOUT AND THEY MOVE AROUND
AND THEY'RE HARD TO TRACK AND
ALL THE SUDDEN THEY SHOW UP AT
KINDERGARTEN AND THEY HAVEN'T
DONE ANY OF THIS STUFF AND
THEY'RE AT THE AGE TO GOING TO
GET ARE SIX YEARS OLD. WHAT
HAPPENS AT THAT POINT. IT IS
MANDATORY THEY DON'T HAVE THAT
PRE CLASS THEY CAN'T CAN THEY
GET IN OR THEY CAN'T GET AND
THAT'S THAT'S WHEN THEY CAN GET
IN BUT THEY WOULD HAVE TO
COMPLETE A FULL YEAR OF
KINDERGARTEN IN ORDER TO. TO BE
PROMOTED TO FIRST GRADE SO WHEN
THEY COME AND THEY WOULD HAVE
TO COMPLETE THAT ONE YEAR. AND
I YOU KNOW AND TO SHARE- AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN BUT YOU
KNOW WHEN WE TALK ABOUT. OUR
STUDENTS MOVING AROUND. EVEN
IN. MIDDLE SCHOOL AND HIGH
SCHOOL THAT'S A SCENARIO THAT
HAPPENS THROUGHOUT OUR SCHOOL-
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS HOWEVER.
IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A SIX
YEAR OLD. THEY WOULD STILL HAVE
TO COMPLETE THAT FIRST YEAR OF
KINDERGARTEN BEFORE BEING
PROMOTED TO FIRST GRADE. OKAY
MAYBE I'M THIS IS MY FIRST.
YEAR ON THIS COMMITTEE AND I
I'M NOT THE EXPERT ON. WHAT
AGES KIDS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
WHERE BUT THAT WOULD MEAN THAT
YOU WOULD BE SEVEN YEARS OLD
WHEN YOU GOING TO FIRST GRADE.
YES LET ME TRY AND HELP SO IN
CALIFORNIA SIX YEARS OLD IT IS
COMPULSORY THAT YOU HAVE TO
SEND YOUR CHILD TO SCHOOL. I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE ASKING CENTER
AT ALL YOU'RE JUST ABOUT GOT
THERE WAS IF YOU DON'T SEND
YOUR CHILD. TO KINDERGARTEN AT
FIVE AND YOU SEND THEM TO
SCHOOL AT SIX. YES I SAID RUBIO
LET ME KNOW IF I'M WRONG. THEY
WOULD START KINDERGARTEN AT SIX
YEARS OLD AND THEN THEY WOULD
START. FIRST GRADE AT SEVEN
YEARS OLD CORRECT. SO
TECHNICALLY I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING THEY COULD BE A YEAR.
OLDER THAN SOME OF THE OTHER
CHILDREN IN THE CLASSROOM. IT
ECONOMIC. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
FOR THAT BUT I WANT TO ADD THAT
OUR 4% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE. IN
THAT SCENARIO THAT THE JUSTICE
SO IT'S NOT AN UNUSUAL.
CIRCUMSTANCE AND I ALSO KNOW
THAT IT EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT
TAKES. REALLY SERIOUSLY YOU
KNOW ABOUT THE WELL BEING OF A
CHILD AS AN ADMINISTRATOR I
FOUND MYSELF THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
CHILDREN WERE BEING SUCCESSFUL.
BY WAY OF EXAMPLE. INSTEAD OF
RETRAINING A CHILD WE WOULD
TAKE THE WHOLE PICTURE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE AGE THE SIZE
OF THE CHILD. YOU KNOW AND
PARENT INPUT CELL SO THERE ARE
SAFEGUARDS BECAUSE YOU KNOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO CARE ABOUT
THE WELL BEING OF THE CHILD
FILL. ON A CASE BY CASE BASIS
IN THAT PARTICULAR INCIDENT.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WOULD DO
YOU KNOW WOULD MAKE EVERY
EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT THE
CHILD'S BEST. INTEREST IS TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO DOLLY MEMBERS IN
OTHER. SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK
YOU OF THAT SURE LEYVA WANTED
JUST TO. NOTE THAT THIS IS A
LEGISLATION THAT'S BEFORE US
HAS SOME RICH HISTORY AND
EFFORTS BY PREVIOUS MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE I KNOW ASSEMBLY
WOMAN- BE CANNON FROM MY- AREA
HAD- MOVED AT THIS TYPE OF
LEGISLATION THAT- EIGHT YEARS
AGO- AND- I YET I PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE THE EXPERTISE THAT
THE AUTHOR BRINGS TO THIS
SUBJECT MATTER- BEING A
PREVIOUS TEACHER I GUESS YOU'RE
ALWAYS A TEACHER YOU NEVER STOP
TEACHING- AND I WELL I
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE SOME
QUESTIONS THAT STILL REMAIN AND
CERTAINLY THE FISCAL ISSUES
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A CHALLENGING
ONE. IN THIS SPACE AS IT IS IN
PRE K. THE ISSUE OF PRE K. I
THINK THIS BILL DESERVES TO GO
FORWARD AND- WITH MY SUPPORT.
AND BE HAPPY TO MOVE IT AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR GLAZERS. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR- SEEING NONE TO
REVIEW WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
FIRST OF ALL I JUST WANTED ALL
MY FOR X. THEIR CONCERNS AND
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
CONTINUE TO MONITOR VERY
CLOSELY AND WORK WITH THEM. WE
JUST GOT SOME LATE MINUTE-
OPPOSITION THAT I HAD NOT
SPOKEN OR HEARD OF SO I WILL
REACH OUT TO THEM I WANT
EVERYONE TO FEEL CONFIDENT THAT
THIS IS IN THE BEST INTERESTS
OF THE CHILDREN AND- BEING A
TEACHER FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS
I'VE SEEN IT ALL. AND OUR KIDS
DESERVE TO START. EQUALLY WITH
THEIR PEERS AND NOT FALL BEHIND
AND FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT I ASKED
FOR AND I BILL. THANK YOU
CENTER RUBIO THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR GLAZERS MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB
SEVENTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
LEYVA ALL LIVE A LIFE OF
SHOWBOAT NO MITCHELL BOTH KNOW
FOR TENNESSEE- PROTEST. DELHI.
DALY GLAZER. AYE GLAZER AYE.
MCGUIRE PAN BY HAND I. WE
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
SENATOR PER. US INTO RUBY U. L.
ALSO AS BEFORE EIGHTY EIGHT
PLEASE WHEN YOU'RE. THANK YOU.
SO ONCE AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR OP NOT TODAY STAND YOU
TO PRESENT SB FOUR EIGHTY A
BILL MY ON HAS BEEN WORKING ON
FOR THREE HERE WITHOUT ME WITH
ALL STATE AND MAKE SURE THAT IS
WHERE HE NEEDS TO FIRST I WOULD
LIKE. THANK THE STAKEHOLDERS
MEETING WITH US A CONSISTENTLY
IN THE COMMITTEE CHAIR AND
STAFF ALONG WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR WORKING
AGAIN CLOSELY ON THIS CRITICAL
MEASURE RELATED TO TEACHER
CREDENTIALING SB FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT MAKES NECESSARY CHANGES
IN ORDER TO DRIVE BETTER
READING COMPREHENSION OUTCOMES
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE CDC TO
REVISE THEIR TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAM STANDARDS
AND REACHING AND TEACHING
PERFORMANCE EXPECTATIONS FOR
LITERACY BY SEPTEMBER FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. ADDITIONALLY
IT ALLOWS CANDIDATES WHO HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO TAKE THE RICA
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC TO TAKE A
CTC APPROVED ASSESSMENT IN
READING INSTRUCTION AND FINALLY
REQUIRES A CTC TO UPDATE THE
TEACHING PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENT
EPA'S TO REPLACE THE RICO BY
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
THE T. P. A.'S ARE NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED AS THE GOLD STANDARD
FOR CANDID ASSESSMENTS AND
ACCORDING TO RESEARCH THE ONLY
ASSESSMENT THAT HAS BEEN SHOWN
TO SIGNIFICANTLY PREDICT
TEACHER EFFECTIVENESS. MEMBERS
WITH NOT ONLY SEEN PUBLIC
SCHOOL SUFFER FROM RECORD
DECLINE IN EMPLOYMENT AS STATED
EARLIER IN CALIFORNIA OR ALSO
CREE EXPERIENCING A TEACHER
SHORTAGE THAT IS AFFECTING MORE
THAN 80% OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS SB FORTY A WILL NOT
ONLY ADDRESS THE NEED TO UPDATE
OUR CURRENT CREDENTIALING
STANDARDS BUT IT WILL ALSO
INCREASE CREASE TEACHER DIVERSE
CITY WHILE DIRECTING DIRECTLY
ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S TEACHER
SHORTAGE AMOUNT OF CHAIRED BY
MAY I WANT TO INTRODUCE. UP.
MIGHT WITNESSES ARE. DR ME
MILLER OF I WAS SURE WE WERE
ABLE TO TAKE ON THE- OKAY ARE
YOU DONE WITH YOUR- WHICH MOVE
IS A- THE SENATE HEALTH OR- YES
I WANTED TO ENTER. A MAYBE
MILLER A IMPROVE. AT STATE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR MAY
MODERATOR WE ARE LOOKING FOR
DOCTOR MILLER IF SHE Q. UP.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU-
GOOD MORNING TEACHER LEYVA AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY DOCTOR
MEANING THAT A PROFESSOR THE
SCHOOL EDUCATION AT CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY CHICO FOR TWENTY
YEARS I'VE ELEMENTARY T. AND
STATE ACT ACCREDITED PROGRAM
LIKE I BETTER CREDIT HELP I'M
VERY BIGGER AT CANNON AT MONTHS
COMPLETE. COURSEWORK THAT ALLOW
THE COMMISSION AND LEAST SIX
HUNDRED OUR- CLASSROOM TEACHING
WHILE THE SUPER AND BY THE
MENTOR MUST ALSO PASS SHE
PERFORMANCE OF. ON IN BOTH
LETTERS THE IN MAPPING OUT
THESE AREN'T YOUR REGULAR HAVE
AND PAPER TESTS CANDID DOCUMENT
THERE TO WITH VIDEO AND BRING.
THEY SAID THAT THEY WERE CARE
CENTER YOU A BY CAL SCORED
THROUGHOUT THE EDUCATE IN
ADDITION TO BE- REQUIREMENTS IN
A THAT THEY MET EACH PATH THE
OUT OF. THE VALIDITY WE DO NOT
KNOW THAT A TEACHER WHO PASSES
THE RICA IS A BETTER TEACHER
THAN SOMEONE WHO DOESN'T PATH
LEADING AND THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE ESPECIALLY WHEN
THESE OTHER DOCUMENTS LIKE THE
TEACHING PERFORMANCE
ASSESSMENTS HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO
PREDICT FUTURE EFFECTIVENESS.
SECOND WE CAN DOES NOT ALIGN
WITH CURRENT STATE ADOPTED
STANDARDS OR FRAMEWORKS THESE
CURRENT GUIDING DOCUMENTS
RETAIN THE ESSENTIAL COMPONENTS
OF READING INSTRUCTION.
INCLUDING FOUNDATIONAL READING
BUT THEY ALSO INCLUDE A MUCH
STRONGER EMPHASIS ON LANGUAGE
ACQUISITION. FOR BOTH NATIVE
AND NON NATIVE ENGLISH SPEAKERS.
BECAUSE IT IS A LINE TO OUT OF
STATE STANDARDS THAT WE CAN
HELP CAN THE- ESSENTIAL
KNOWLEDGE BUT NOT THE MOST UP
TO DATE PEDAGOGY NEEDED TO
TEACH CALIFORNIA CHILDREN. SB
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT MIN MOVES THE
RATE CAPS AND INSTEAD ENSURES
THAT THE ABILITY TO TEACH
FOUNDATIONAL READING AT THE
FACTORY STATE APPROVED TEACHING
PERFORMANCE ASSESSMENTS THAT
ARE BASED ON CURRENT STANDARD.
AND I VOTE ON SB FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT WILL ENSURE THAT NEW
TEACHERS TO ENTER CALIFORNIA
CLASSROOMS HAVE DEMONSTRATED
THAT THEY ARE WELL PREPARED TO
TEACH THEIR. STUDENTS HOW TO
READ. THANK YOU. THANK VERY
MUCH STRUCTURE MILLER. WE HAVE
NO OTHER LEAD SUPPORT SO WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE GALLERY
SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE. SEEING NO ONE
MATTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT. FOR THOSE
SPEAKING JUST STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER THE PLACE YOU BACK INTO-Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEIR THEIR OWN NOW. THE
MANAGER LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE
ABOUT FIVE PARTICIPANTS QUEUING
UP THANK YOU. LIE NUMBER SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BRENDAN TO WORK ON BEHALF OF
ADVICE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS CHERYL OF-
EXECUTOR IF YOU'RE DEPRESSED
HEALTH CORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
OFFICIAL PROGRAM WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MOM JERRY
CAN YOU MARK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT EDUCATIONAL
THIRDS ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
THE FIFTY EIGHT HUNDRED COULD
BRING HELEN IN SUPPORT OF THE
FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
BELLICOSITY AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THE BALLOT. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEFF
AKA REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
I'M SURE WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
ELSE TO ENOUGH AT THE MOMENT
ONE MOMENT. MY NUMBER EIGHTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SHRAN ROUTE SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STOCKS P. ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT
AND ONE AT THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU. AND AT THIS TIME AND
I'M SURE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
MEMBER WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION. HERE IN THE GALLERY
I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
I SEE NO ONE MAN MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION SB FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF
SB FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT. BUT PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR
WILL TAKE YOUR- MIND OFF LINE
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR MY
NUMBER THEN PUT YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT. PRESS ONE THEN
THEIR OWN NOW. I'M SURE WE DO
HAVE ONE PERSON QUEUING UP ONE
MOMENT THANK YOU. BUT I NUMBER
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
MAUREEN GRAVES I'M CO CHAIR OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
PARENT CHILD ADVOCACY- WHICH IS
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT- WILL YOU HAVE THE SAME
NAME AND OPPOSITION THANK YOU
MA'AM. AND AT THE TIME AND I'M
SURE THERE WAS NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MATTER MODERATOR WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATOR
PAN. I THINK IT'S VERY MUCH A
MADAM CHAIR ADDRESS I WANT
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD- YOU KNOW READING IS-
LOW CRITICAL- HOPEFULLY
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THAT AND-
CERTAINLY TRYING TO DRESS OF
READING ISSUES INCLUDING
DYSLEXIA. I THINK IT IS IT IS
IT IS CRITICAL TO THE STUDENTS-
FUTURE SUCCESS. UNFORTUNATELY
TOO OFTEN- BECAUSE OF THAT AND-
AND PARENTS- CONCERNS- IF SUCH
CHILD HAS A DISABILITY RELATED
TO READING THAT- SOMETIMES
THEY'RE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF AND
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT-
TEACHERS WHO ARE TRUSTED-
PARTNERS WITH. PARENTS ACTUALLY
ARE- CAN PROVIDE EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACHES AND HAVE THAT.
TRAINING TO BE ABLE TO DETECT
AND IDENTIFY- READING THIS
AVAIL DISABILITIES RELATED TO
READING IN SCHOOL SO I WANNA
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR YOUR BRAIN
THIS BILL FORD AND ADDRESSING
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE AND BE
SURE AND- AND CERTAINLY VERY
IMPORTANT WE PROVIDE RESOURCES
TO TEACHERS AS WELL. SO THAT
THEY CAN DO THE WORK VITAL WORK
THEY NEED TO DO TO. BOTH
IDENTIFY AND- MANAGE- AS
DISABILITIES LIKE DYSLEXIA AS
WELL SO. I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING THE
ANSWER RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- JUST WANTED QUICKLY
STATE THAT- S. C. GREAT SENATOR
FROM SACRAMENTO- STATED THIS IS
EVIDENCE BASED. APPROACH AND IT
DOES. MAKE SURE THAT TEACHERS
ARE GETTING REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCE IN THE CLASSROOM
WHICH I THINK S SO IMPORTANT
TO MANY TIMES HE HAD. TEACHERS
SHOW UP IN THE FIRST YEAR.
LEAVE THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE SAME WHEN
YOU HAVE REAL LIFE CHILDREN IN
FRONT OF YOU. AND THIS WILL
ENCOURAGE TEACHERS TO ACTUALLY
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT
INSTRUCTION. AND TO REALLY
TACKLE THE ISSUES IN A REAL
LIFE SETTING SO. I WANTED TO
JUST CLOSE BY SAYING THAT SB
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT WILL PRESERVE
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH. STANDARDS
FOR TEACHING PREPARATION. IT
WILL JEFF THE TEACHER SHORTAGE
THANK. TEACHER DIVERSE. AND IT
WILL LET. THE- THE THAT GREAT
CENTER FROM. STATED THAT IT
WILL ALSO INCLUDE- DYSLEXIA-
DANDER CHILL WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ENABLE
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
RUBIO THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR PAN MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SB FOUR EIGHTY
EIGHT THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA HI
LEYVA I WOULD SHOW ABOVE. BUT
CHAU BOGUE COURTESY CURTIS III
DELI DELI HI GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN PAN I THINK YOU
WILL LEAVE THAT ALONE ON CALL
FOR SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO NEXT UP WE HAVE
SENATOR WIENER WITH SB. THREE
SEVENTY NINE CENTER WIENER
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO YOUR IN
YOUR COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
US. OUR COLLEAGUE SENATE BILL
THREE SEVENTY NINE- WILL
PROHIBIT- THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH SYSTEM. FROM
ENTERING INTO ANY CONTRACT WITH
ANOTHER HEALTH FACILITY. THAT
LIMITS THE SERVICES THAT YOU
SEE PROVIDERS OR STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE PATIENTS. DUE
TO NON CLINICAL DISCRIMINATORY
RESTRICTIONS ON CARE. YOU SEE
HEALTH SYSTEM IS ONE OF THE
BEST HEALTH SYSTEMS IN THE
NATION. AND THE WORLD RENOWNED
FOR ITS LEADERSHIP. ON AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AND LGBTQ
INCLUSIVE HEALTH CARE WE SHOULD
ALL BE EXTREMELY PROUD. OF YOU
SEE HEALTH. UCHEALTH IS ALSO
THE FOURTH LARGEST HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA. AND THE
UC RECEIVES APPROXIMATELY NINE
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE STATE-
EACH YEAR. BY YOU SEE PLAYS A
CENTRAL ROLE IN TRAINING
MEDICAL STUDENTS AND IN
PROVIDING HEALTHCARE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS ARE TREATED BY YOU
SEE DOCTORS. NURSES STAFF AND
STUDENTS EVERY YEAR AND ONE OF
UC'S CORE VALUES IS INCLUSIVE
HEALTH CARE. BUT NO MATTER WHO
YOU ARE. NO MATTER HOW
MARGINALIZED YOU ARE NO MATTER
HOW MUCH SOCIETY HAS WRITTEN
YOU OFF AND SAID YOU HAVE NO
VALUE YOU SEE WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH HEALTHCARE. IN PARTICULAR
UC PROVIDES EXCEPTIONALLY
STRONG ACCESS TO REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE. AND GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE FOR TRANS PEOPLE.
DESPITE ALL OF THIS AND DESPITE
THE SCORE YOU SEE VALUES OF
INCLUSION BUT HEALTHCARE ACCESS
WHICH OUR CALIFORNIA VALUES
DESPITE THE- UCHEALTH HAS
ENTERED INTO CONTRACTS. AND
PLANS TO SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND
ITS CONTRACTS OVER TIME. WITH
HEALTHCARE FACILITIES THAT
IMPOSE RESTRICTIONS ON MEDICAL
CARE BETTER NOT BASED ON
SCIENCE AND THAT ARE NOT BASED
ON ANY CLINICAL CRITERIA. THIS
RESTRICTIONS CAN BE BASED ON
POLITICAL VIEWS FOR EXAMPLE A
HOSPITAL MANAGEMENTS DECISION
THAT IS POLITICALLY OPPOSED. TO
CERTAIN PROCEDURES OR FOR
EXAMPLE RELIGIOUS VIEWS FOR
EXAMPLE WHEN A BISHOP
DETERMINES THAT CERTAIN HEALTH
CARE VIOLATES RELIGIOUS
DOCTRINE OR OTHER RESTRICTIONS
NOT BASED. ON SCIENCE OR
CLINICAL DECISION MAKING. AS
PART OF UC'S CONTRACTS WITH
THESE HOSPITALS. YOU SEE
PHYSICIANS NURSES MEDICAL
STUDENTS ARE PROHIBITED FROM
PERFORMING THESE RESTRICTED
HEALTH CARE PROCEDURES ON YOU
SEE PATIENTS WHEN THEY'RE
PRACTICING AND IS AFFILIATED
HOSPITALS. YOU HEARD THAT RIGHT
ARE YOU SEE PHYSICIAN WEARING A
UC BAD. BEING PAID BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA CAN BE
PROHIBITED. PERFORMING
HEALTHCARE ON PATIENT EVEN IF
THE OPPOSITION BELIEVES THAT
THE HEALTH CARE IS APPROPRIATE
AND MEDICALLY NECESSARY. I WANT
TO BE SPECIFIC SOME OF THE
RESTRICTIVE CONTRACTS THAT YOU
THINK YOU SEE HEALTH HAZARD AND
TO. EXPLICITLY PROHIBIT YOU SEE
DOCTORS AND STUDENTS FROM THE
FOLLOWING. FROM TREATING A
MISCARRIAGE WHICH IN SOME
HOSPITALS IS CONSIDERED TO BE
AN ABORTION IF THERE IS STILL A
FETAL HEARTBEAT EVEN IF THE
FETUS IS NOT VIABLE. REQUIRING
APPARENT SYSTEM IN TURMOIL.
WITHOUT HAVING A MISCARRIAGE
TREATED UNTIL THE HEARTBEAT
STOPS. EVEN IF THE PATIENT IS
BLEEDING. ANOTHER XAMPLE
PROVIDING EMERGENCY
CONTRACEPTIVE CONTRACEPTIVES TO
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
PERFORMING A TUBAL LIGATION IN
CONNECTION WITH THE C. SECTION
SO IF SOMEONE COMES IN FOR AN
EMERGENCY C. SECTION AND WANTS
TO HAVE A TUBAL LIGATION AS
PART OF A C. SECTION I CAN'T
HAS TO FINISH THE PROCEDURE AND
THEN GO TO A DIFFERENT
HOSPITAL. TO HAVE A SECOND
PROCEDURE FOR THE TUBAL
LIGATION EVEN OVER THE UC
POSITION PERFORMING THAT C.
SECTION. PERFORMING CERTAIN
SURGERIES TO ADDRESS AT A TOPIC
PREGNANCY FANS. INSERTING AN R.
U. T. AND A WOMAN BANNED THE UC
POSITION CAN DO THAT SOME OF
THESE HOSPITALS PROVIDING
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE TO
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE FOR EXAMPLE
A GYNECOLOGIST CAN'T PERFORM A
HYSTERECTOMY. ON A TRANS PERSON
AS PART OF GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE EVEN THOUGH. OTHER
PATIENTS CAN RECEIVE A
HYSTERECTOMY IN THAT FACILITY.
THESE RESTRICTIONS ENDANGER
LIVES AND THEY DENIED BASIC
HEALTH CARE THE UC POSITION
LEAVES AS APPROPRIATE. THIS
CONTRACTING PROCESS COLLEAGUES
HAS BEEN DONE BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS WITH LIMITED PUBLIC
INFORMATION ON THE IMPACT OF
THIS CONTRACT CONTRACTS ON
BASIC PREVENTIVE CARE. AND
URGENT CARE. THESE DECISIONS
ABOUT PATIENTS ADVOCATES
LAWMAKERS AND EVEN
PRACTITIONERS IN THE DARK ON
WHAT THESE CONTRACTS MEAN FOR
THE CARE THAT PATIENTS ARE
PROVIDED AT THESE FACILITIES.
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED YOU SEE COMMUNITY
MEMBERS DOCTORS NURSES TRAINEES
STUDENTS STAFF HAVE SIGNED AN
OPEN LETTER EXPRESSING THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THESE
DISCRIMINATORY RESTRICTIONS.
PHILIBERT NON CLINICAL AND NON
SCIENCE BASED HEALTHCARE
RESTRICTIONS THAT I BASIC CARE
AND SERVICES TO COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE PROTECTED BY
CALIFORNIA LAW. THIS HAS A
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
PATIENTS OF COLOR PATIENTS WITH
LOW INCOME. LGBTQ PEOPLE PEOPLE
WHO ALREADY FACE TREMENDOUS
BARRIERS TO CARE. I WANTED TO
KNOW THAT YOU'VE SEEN RECEIVE
OPPOSITION LETTERS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
FROM THE CATHOLIC HOSPITALS AND
A LETTER OF CONCERN FROM YOU
SEE. THESE LETTERS AND I JUST
WANT TO BE HONEST HAVE BEEN
LESS THAN STRAIGHTFORWARD.
ABOUT THE SEVERITY OF THE
RESTRICTIONS. BOB AT ABOUT THE
IMPACTS TO CARE. THE OPPOSITION
AND CONCERN LETTERS BARELY EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT THESE
RESTRICTIONS EXIST THEY MAKE IT
SEEM LIKE EVERYONE GETS ALL THE
CARE THAT THEY NEED AT THESE
FACILITIES WHICH IS SIMPLY
UNTRUE. A CATHOLIC HOSPITALS
LETTER TALKS ABOUT HOW THE
CAPITALIST WORLD PROVIDE ALL
SORTS OF CARE TO LGBTQ PEOPLE
WITHOUT MENTIONING THAT THE
EXPLICITLY DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
TRANS PEOPLE AND TELL THEM YOU
CAN'T GET SERVICES IN THIS
HOSPITAL YOU NEED TO GO TO
ANOTHER HOSPITAL. IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING. IF
THE UC THINKS THAT IT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR YOU SEE
POSITION TO BE PROHIBITED FROM
PERFORMING A TUBAL LIGATION
DURING A C. SECTION. OR FROM
FROM- FROM PROVIDING GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE. THE YOU SAY THE
UC SHOULDN'T DANCE AROUND THAT
THE UC SHOULD SAY IT. AND YOU
SEE SAID EXPLICITLY ADMIT THESE
RESTRICTIONS AND THE FANDOM.
YOU SEE DOESN'T DO THAT. THEY
DON'T TALK ABOUT THE SPECIFICS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T DEFEND THEM
BECAUSE FRANKLY I THINK THEY'RE
EMBARRASSED TO DEFEND THEM
BECAUSE THESE RESTRICTIONS
COMPLETELY CONTRADICT YOU SEE
VALUES. THE IMPACTS THAT WE SEE
FROM THE OPPOSITION THIS IS
GOING TO AND CARE FOR POOR
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA FOR
MEDICAL PATIENTS THAT IS SIMPLY
UNTRUE THIS IS A TINY
PERCENTAGE. OF THE UC- REVENUE
OF YOU SEE CARE WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THIS WILL
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE IN THE
FUTURE AS YOU SEE AS PART OF
ITS BUSINESS STRATEGY EXPANDS
THESE DISCRIMINATORY
AFFILIATIONS. AND IN TERMS OF
CARE. IT IS NOT GOOD CARE TO
TELL PEOPLE ON MEDICARE ALL
THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO PROVIDE
YOU WITH CARE THE MEDICAL
COVERS WHETHER IT'S GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH. IF THE UC SHARES THE
VALUES OF DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION AND I BELIEVE THAT
YOU SEE ABSOLUTELY SHARE THE
VALUES THAT IT SHOULD NOT BE
DEFENDING HIS CONTRACTS AT THE
EXPENSE. OF THE LIVES AND WELL
BEING OF WOMEN AND LGBTQ PEOPLE
AND YOU SEE SHOULD BE ACTIVELY
SEEKING ALTERNATIVES. WE ARE
SEEING COLLEAGUES TRENDS AROUND
THE COUNTRY WITH STATE MAKING
IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR WOMEN TO GET
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE AND WE
KNOW THERE ARE STATES WHERE
THAT IS EFFECTIVELY IMPOSSIBLE
ANYWHERE IN THE STATE. AND WE
SEE STATES NOW BANNING GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE. FOR PEOPLE
UNDER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN. WE
SHOULD NOT BE ENABLING AND
PROMOTING POLICIES IN
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE IT HARDER
AND HARDER FOR WOMEN AND LGBTQ
PEOPLE TO RECEIVE THE CARE THAT
THEY NEED. BOB THIS LEGISLATION
IS SPONSORED BY EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA BY NAY ROLE AND THE
ACLU AND SUPPORTED BY PLANNED
PARENTHOOD HEALTH ACCESS AND A
HUGE COALITION. OF HEALTH
JUSTICE AND LGBT. ORGANIZATIONS
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME
TODAY TESTIFIED OUR DOCTOR
VANESSA JACOBY A GYNECOLOGIST A
UCSF. LARA AND EVAN. A TRANS
MAN WHO WAS DENIED GENDER
AFFIRMING HEALTH CARE- WITH US
TODAY ALSO NOT TO SPEAK BUT TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS IS
ELIZABETH GILL WITH THE ACLU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR WIENER-
MADAME MODERATOR IF YOU WILL
QUEUE UP OUR TO LEAD WITNESSES
DR JACOBY AND EVAN MINTON
PLEASE. BLINDER OPEN. YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES. HEY THIS IS
EVAN MINTON THANK YOU CHARLIE
THAT MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
AM HONORED TO BE A WITNESS MANY
OF YOU KNOW MY STORY BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT YOU HEARING
TODAY. SEVERAL YEARS AGO MY
DOCTORS DETERMINED THAT A
HYSTERECTOMY WAS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY FOR ME AS PART OF MY
COURSE OF TREATMENT FOR GENDER
DYSPHORIA I WAS SCHEDULED TO
UNDERGO THE SURGERY AT MERCY
SAN JUAN MEDICAL CENTER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. TWO DAYS BEFORE THE
SURGERY I MENTIONED TO A NURSE
THAT I WAS TRANSGENDER. THE
VERY NEXT DAY DAYS. BEFORE MY
SURGERY WAS SUPPOSED TO TAKE
PLACE. THE HOSPITAL CANCELED IT.
EVEN THOUGH MY DOCTOR REGULARLY
PERFORMS HYSTERECTOMIES AT
MERCY SAN JUAN SHE WAS INFORMED
THAT SHE WOULD NEVER BE ALLOWED
TO PERFORM THE OPERATION ON ME.
IN SHORT BECAUSE I AM
TRANSGENDER. WHEN I HEARD THE
NEWS I REMEMBER BEING SO
DEVASTATED THAT I CLAPPED TO
THE GROUND I WAS HORRIFIED. AT
THE HOSPITAL WHICH REFUSING TO
TREAT ME SIMPLY BECAUSE OF WHO
I AM. TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE THE
FACT THAT THE SURGERY WAS
CANCELED AND DANGEROUSLY PUT
ALL OF THE OTHER TREATMENTS I
HAD SCHEDULED AN FLAT. THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IS MY
ALMA MATER. I AM TESTIFYING
TODAY BECAUSE THEY HAD ENTERED
INTO CONTRACTS WITH MERCY SAN
JUAN AND OTHER HOSPITALS LIKE
IT. UNDER THESE CONTRACTS THANK
YOU SEE DOCTOR PRACTICING AT
MERCY SAN JUAN WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO DENY. TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE CARE. I AM ALSO
TESTIFYING TODAY BECAUSE
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE WHO
EXPERIENCE DISCRIMINATION R. TO
WHY. I'M GONNA REPEAT THAT
TWICE AS LIKELY TO COMMIT
SUICIDE. PLEASE DON'T ALLOW THE
UC TO REQUIRE DISCRIMINATION.
PLEASE DON'T PUT LIVES AT RISK.
THANK YOU MISTER MINTON NEXT UP
DR JACOBY PLEASE BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING I DON'T OBSTETRICIAN
GYNECOLOGIST AT UC SAN
FRANCISCO I GRADUATED FROM UC
BERKELEY AND I DID ALL OF MY
MEDICAL TRAINING AT UCSF. THANK
YOU SEE I HAVE BEEN INSTILLED
WITH OUR CORE VALUES TO PROVIDE
HIGH QUALITY CARE FOR ALL
PATIENTS IN AN ENVIRONMENT FREE
OF DISCRIMINATION. THAT IS
PRECISELY WHY I SUPPORT SB
THREE SEVENTY NINE. THE MOST
COMMON POLICY BASED
RESTRICTIONS IN CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS PROHIBIT ME FROM
PLACING AN IED ONE OF THE MOST
EFFECTIVE METHODS OF
CONTRACEPTION. EIGHT PROHIBIT
ME FROM PERFORMING A TUBAL
LIGATION EVEN DURING A SUPERION
SECTION THE MOST EFFECTIVE TIME
FOR TRIPLE IDEATION. WHEN I
CARE FOR A PATIENT WITH A
MISCARRIAGE I MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO PERFORM STANDARD PROCEDURES
TO REMOVE AND NONVIABLE AND
BRIO. THEY PROHIBIT BURN AND
ELDER NATION AND IN VITRO
FERTILIZATION THESE ARE THE
ONLY MEDICAID AVAILABLE FOR
LGBT PEOPLE TO HAVE BIOLOGICAL
CHILDREN. AND I AM PROHIBITED
FROM DOING A HYSTERECTOMY FOR A
TRANSGENDER PERSON EVEN THOUGH
ALL OF MY OTHER PATIENTS CAN
UNDERGO HYSTERECTOMY.
TRANSFERRING MY PATIENT TO
ANOTHER HOSPITAL FOR THE
SERVICES DOES NOT MITIGATE THE
HARM. IF I WORK IN A HOSPITAL
THAT PROHIBITS ESSENTIAL
REPRODUCTIVE AND GENDER
AFFIRMING HEALTHCARE IT FEELS
LIKE STANDING UNDER A SIGN ON
THE DOOR THAT SAYS WE DON'T
SERVE WOMEN AND LGBT PEOPLE ALL.
THAT IS NOT THE CARE I SHOULD
PROVIDE WEARING MY NEWSFEED
BAGGAGE WHEN I REPRESENT THE
VALUES AND PRINCIPLES OF OUR
RENOWNED PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. THAT IS NOT THE CARE I
WAS TAUGHT TO PROVIDE IN MY UC
TRAINING IT'S NOT THE CARE I
KNOW TEACH. MEDICAL STUDENTS. I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU DR
JACOBY MEMBERS WE WILL NOW G
TO THE GALLERY FOR SUPPORT
SEEING NONE ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEING NONE WE WILL NOW GO TO
OUR LINE'S MADAM MODERATOR FEW
WOULD OPEN THE LINES FOR PEOPLE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE THOUSAND SUPPORT STATE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION AND
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR BUT EVEN
THOUGH I DON'T MIND IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK IN
THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVENTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW. THE MANAGER
OF THAT WE HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
TWO PARTICIPANTS IN Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR RONALD KOEMAN HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND APOLOGIZE
FOR LATE LETTER. THANK YOU.
LINE MY NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU MARTIN ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIANS PROUD
SPONSORED BY THREE THREE
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS JESSICA MORROW AND I'M
A REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH RESEARCH
COORDINATOR YOU CAN'T STOP I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THAT SEVEN I THINK YOU. LINE
ONE OH THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
YES MEAN PALLID WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
FIVE ONE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI KATHY VAN OFTEN
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOUR MEMBERS
KATHY MUST WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION OF CALIFORNIA COSPONSORED
AND SUPPORTED A THREE THREE
SEVEN NINE. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
FRIEND WHAT PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA AND
START QUITE ABOUT SB THREE
THOUSAND NINE THANK YOU. WHY
NUMBER NINETY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
SONYA COACH ARE THE LAST FROM-
GENET REPRODUCTIVE AND GENDER
EQUITY AND STRONGSUPPORT SB
THREE SEVEN NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER EIGHTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE THIS IS ALLIE
HE FROM NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER NINETY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
ON BEHALF OF CHEECH TRAINING
RELATIONS OF COMPREHENSIVE
HEALTH CARE A TRAINING PROGRAM
THAT WHICH IS FOR YOU TO A
POPULATED FAMILY MEDICINE
RESIDENCIES AND WE ARE TALKING
SB THREE SEVEN NINE THANK YOU
THANK. YOU WHY NUMBER NINE FIVE
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HERMAN TO THE FOR FROM
YES FAMILY COMMUNITY EVERY PER
INTO HELPED INDUSTRY SUPPORT OF
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU. WELL
MY NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THE NEW YORK JOHNMYERS ON
BEHALF OF THE WESTERN. AND LONG
PROPERTY IS SUPPORTIVE SB THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
PAUL HANNON UT ALUM IN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF MEDICAL STUDENTS
FOR CHOICE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVENTY NINE. MY NUMBER
ONE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- TIM
VALDERRAMA WITH THE VITAMIN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF COMPASSION
AND CHOICES ACTION NETWORK. FOR
THE NATION'S OLDEST AND LARGEST
NATIONAL NONPROFIT FOCUSING ON
END OF LIFE HEALTH CARE AND
WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. LIE NUMBER NINETY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
LIBBY BENEDICT REPRESENTING THE
WOMEN'S FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA
AND CROWD ALONE- UCLA IN STRONG
STRONG SUPPORT OF B THREE
SEVEN NINE THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS ELEANOR DROP I AM A
PROFESSOR OF OBSTETRICS
GYNECOLOGY AND REPRODUCTIVE
SCIENCES AT UCSF. YES I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER ONE OH TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF
THOUSANDS OF ADVOCATES WITH THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF JEWISH
WOMEN CALIFORNIA I STATE ARE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE OH SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS TERRIBLE I'M A
SENIOR PROJECT MANAGER AT YOU
CAN'T THAT AND I'M CALLING
STRONG SUPPORT SB THREE SEVEN
NINE. MY NUMBER ONE OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DR SALINAS ANIMAL AND OBGYN
WITH UC SAN DIEGO AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE SEVEN
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER NINETY ONE THE IS OPEN
TO GO AHEAD. MAKING A MAN SHOT
I AM A YOU SEE IT THAT THEM FOR
YOU AND WOMEN'S FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA WOMEN'S POLICY
INSTITUTE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
RIGHTS AND JUSTICE BELLO IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LIE
NUMBER NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS MATTHEW RYAN- BEFORE
HERE MD PHD STUDENT AT UCF
STAFF AND A MEMBER OF THE LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY KERN STRONG
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING GOING BACK IF I AM THE
FATHER OF A TRANS PERSON AND ON
BEHALF OF MY CLIENTS DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE HELLO BAKER
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE ELEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI SHANNON
OLIVIERI HOLDEN ON BEHALF OF
NARAL PRO CHOICE CALIFORNIA
WHERE ONE OF THE COULD SPONSORS
ON THE BALLOT AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS EMILY
ESCOBAR WITH THE FEMINIST
MAJORITY FOUNDATION I'M CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM MODERATOR. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION WE
DO HAVE TO LEAD OPPOSITION
CATHERINE SCOTT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. AND CLICK HERE AND
FLATTERY- FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA MISS SCOTT ARE
YOU READY. I AM GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING BILL RIGHT HEY
KATHERINE ABOUT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS THAT THE
ASIAN- AFFILIATIONS AMONG
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH SYSTEMS
ARE CANADIAN HELP TO ENSURE
ACCESS TO PATIENTS ACROSS ALL
PATIENT CARE ENVIRONMENT. THE
TECHNOLOGICAL SPECIALTY CARE
SERVICES INCLUDING PEDIATRIC
CARE CANCER CARE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT AND CRITICALLY
RELEVANT TO THE COMMUNITY THE
COMMITTEE. THE SOLUTIONS
INCLUDE THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION OF HUNDREDS OF
PHYSICIANS IN TRAINING A
RESIDENCY PROGRAM COSTS EIGHT.
THIS BILL WOULD UNDERMINE AND
COULD UNRAVEL ACCESS VITAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY FOR LOW
INCOME AND GLOBAL POPULATIONS
AND AS A RESULT THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION NOT YET
CLOSE. BECAUSE OF THE EXTENT OF
WORK WITH THE UC SYSTEM WITH
MANY OF OUR HOSPITALS INCLUDING
RELIGIOUSLY AFFILIATED
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS MANY OF
THE SHARED PROGRAM BENEFIT
PATIENTS SIMPLE UNDERSERVED AND
MARGINALIZED THE- PROGRAM
SUPPORT ON MEDICAL THINKING
THAT ENTRY- STATE. MOST OF THE
LOCATION THE FILIATION FROM
HOSPITAL LIKELY YOU'D BE TO
EXPAND ITS EXPERTISE. THREE
SUBSEQUENTLY READ. HEALTH
NORMAL. ONE OF ALL. COPLEY
PROPER. IT IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT THE BILL IS VERY BROAD ARE
YOU SEE HEALTH. AND BEAUTY HELD
A CONTRACT WITH MANY HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AND ALL HOSPITALS WE CULTIVATE
THE PHYSICIAN. ABOUT THE
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED IN
THE HOSPITAL THAT COULD BE
CONSTRUED AS NON CLINICAL.
REASON COULD BE BASED ON
CLINICAL NEED QUALITY MEASURES
FOR THE LICENSING REQUIREMENTS
OR LIMITATIONS. SEVERAL
PARTNERSHIPS LIKE THOSE WITH
YOU SEE ARE CRITICAL TO
ENSURING ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
CARE AND PROVIDER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES. FOCUSING ON THE
MOST RELEVANT FOR THE COMMITTEE
TODAY CLINICAL EDUCATION AND
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS ARE FOR
PHYSICIANS NURSES AND OTHER
ALLIED HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
BECAUSE OF THE DIFFICULT IN
MULTIPLE STATES. FROM ABOUT
MULTIPLE SITES EXCUSE ME FROM
VIOLATE THE HUMBLE I'M
PROVIDING CRITICAL CARE
CRITICAL EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED RESIDENTS
IN TRAINING FOR EXAMPLE OUR
INDIGNITY HEALTH ABILITY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE RATE
INCREASE INLAND EMPIRE ARNOLD.
SOME OF THESE ARE CRITICALLY
THANK YOU MISCAST. WILL UNDER
THE- BUT YOU'VE EXCEEDED YOUR
TIME ARE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS FIND
YOUR INSULARITY UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA STATE GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS I JOIN YOU TO EXPRESS
THE UNIVERSITY CONCERN
COMMISSION ON SB THREE SEVEN
NINE. NOT OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BUT WE DO HAVE CONCERNS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND OTHERS
TO ADDRESS WHAT WE BELIEVE TO
BE SHARED GOAL OF ADVANCING
BOTH NON DISCRIMINATORY MEDICAL
CARE. AND ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
CARE. WOULD LIKE TO THANK
SENATOR WIENER BRING GAUGING
DIRECTLY WITH UC'S PRESIDENT DR
MICHAEL DRAKE OVER MANY MONTHS
TO DISCUSS THESE ISSUES AND WE
ARE HOPEFUL A DIFFERENT PATH
FORWARD CAN BE IDENTIFIED. I
WANT TO START BY SAYING THAT
THE UNIVERSITY IS OPPOSED TO
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS USING NON
MEDICAL POLICIES TO DETERMINE
THE SCOPE OF CARE. IN OTHER
WORDS WE DO NOT AGREE WITH THE
POLICY BASED RESTRICTIONS THAT
SOME HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
IMPOSED THAT LIMITS THE TYPE OF
SERVICES THAT CAN BE PROVIDED
THERE AT THE SAME TIME WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT YOU SEE POSITION.
PLAN IMPORTANT ROLE IN
ADVANCING HIGH QUALITY EVEN
LIFESAVING CARE FOR PEACE IN
PATIENTS WHO SEEK TREATMENT AT
THE FACILITY. SO WE WANT TO
WORK TOWARD ELIMINATING
DISCRIMINATION WE WANT TO WORK
TOWARD ELIMINATING HEALTH
INEQUITY FOR ALL PATIENTS. OUR
CONCERN IS THAT THIS BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT THE UNIVERSITY FROM
SERVING PATIENTS THAT WE
CURRENTLY SIR INCLUDING THOSE
WHO ARE SERIOUSLY L. AND
BENEFIT FROM THE LIFESAVING
TREATMENT YOU SEE PHYSICIANS
PROVIDE. WHAT WE HAVE DONE
AFTER HEARING THE IMPORTANT
CONCERNS RAISED BY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMUNITY AND LEGISLATORS
YOU THE MAN OUR CONTRACTS WITH
THESE PROVIDERS THAT HAVE THESE
POLICY BASED RESTRICTION. TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT OUR POSITION
AND TRAINEES ARE PROTECTED IN
THEIR ABILITY TO ADVISE
PRESCRIBING AND MAKE REFERRALS
IN A WAY THAT IS CONSISTENT
WITH THEIR PROFESSIONAL MEDICAL
JUDGMENT. AND THE NEEDS AND
WISHES OF. THEIR PARENTS THAT
THEIR PATIENTS. THANK YOU VERY
HOPEFUL THAT A DIFFERENT YOU
CAN BE A DE. THANK FIXING ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
WILL NOW NEW MOVE TO OPPOSITION
IN THE GALLERY SEEING THEN WILL
MOVE TO ROOM ONE TWELVE SEEING
NONE. MADAM MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO IS
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE THOSE QUEUING UP
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE SEVENTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE IT
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE SEVENTY NINE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. AND AT THIS
TIME ITEM SHARE THAT WE HAVE
ABOUT SEVEN PARTICIPANTS IN Q.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR. WHY NUMBER ONE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS SAMUEL GREEN AT UCLA ALUM
AND I AM CALLING IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
WHY NUMBER FORTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OR ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE OF
CATHOLIC HEALTH CARE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER NINETY EIGHT THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT THE.
EIGHT PARDON ME. BLIND NINETY
EIGHT. YES JULY NINETY EIGHT OH
OH GOOD I WAS CUT OFF EARLIER
I'M I AM CALLING- REGARDING SB
SEVENTY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVENTY MANDATORY MANNER GARDEN
THANK YOU MAY I AM THE WIFE GOT
NEXT CALLER PLEASE CENTRAL CAL.
MY NUMBER IS SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ROBERT BYRD I'M AN ORGANIZER
WITH PRO LIFE SENTENCES GO AND
AYE OPPOSED THIS BILL AND MUCH
AMENDED TO EXCLUDE ELECTIVE
ABORTION AND ASSISTED SUICIDE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THE LINE
NUMBER NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
DOCTOR ARE CURED ALARM YANG I
AM THE DIRECTOR OF PEDIATRIC
GASTROENTEROL LOGY AT UC DAVIS
MEDICAL CENTER A CLINICAL
PROFESSOR OF PEDIATRICS AND
RETIRED ARMY COLONEL I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS LEGISLATION OF
THREE SEVEN CONCERT NEXT CALLER.
MY NUMBER NINETY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI TO
READ THE BOOK OPEN ACT ATS
DEMOCRATS L. G. B. T. Q. I. A.
ALLY FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PRO LIFE SAN
FRANCISCO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL AS IT'S CURRENTLY
WRITTEN A YEAR. AND AT THIS
TIME AND I'M SURE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE THE
SENATOR PAN. PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ACTUALLY
DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS FOR THE
OPPOSITION YOU TESTIFIED
POSSIBLE CESSATION USE IF
THEY'RE- IF AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
VERY GOOD- IS THAT MISTER
FLATTERY- IF YOU ARE IN QUEUE
IF THE MODERATOR CAN OPEN YOUR
LINES THAT WOULD BE GREAT I'M
HERE. OKAY THANK YOU- SO I YEAH
I APPRECIATE BOTH THE
PRESENTATION FROM THE AUTHOR
AND YOUR OPPOSITION IN FACT
MANY OF THE POINTS YOU MAKE IN
YOUR OPPOSITION NIGHT AT THE
MINUTE DON'T DISAGREE WITH.
SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY WAS
PREVIOUSLY FACULTY MEMBER YOU
SEE IN FACT ACTUALLY I WAS
DIRECTED RESIDENCY PROGRAM- I
GUESS WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND
IS- IS SOMEONE WHO IS OF
SPONSORED BILL FOR THE
EDUCATION OF RESIDENTS AND
CERTAINLY REALIZE HOW DIFFICULT
IS GET CLINICAL SITES AND THE
VALUE OF CLINICAL SITES IN OUR
HOSPITALS RIGHT DIFFERENT
HOSPITAL SOMETIMES NOT ALWAYS
AVAILABLE YOUR HOME CENTER
ACADEMIC HEALTH CENTER. BUT
WIDER AND MY TEACHING. MY
RESIDENT PHYSICIANS. THE ONES
WHO I WILL EVENTUALLY NEED TO
CERTIFY TO BE IN THE FIELD AND
THE FAMILY PRACTICE. IF THEY'RE
A FACILITY. WHERE THEY SEE OR
EXPERIENCE- THE INABILITY TO
PROVIDE THE CARE. THAT IS
RECOMMENDED THE ONES THAT
FOLLOW THE GUIDELINES THAT ARE
PUT OUT BY MY OWN PROFESSION-
IN PEDIATRICS SELF EXAMPLE
TRANSGENDER CARE THE AMERICAN
CAVEAT SIX HAS. SOME VERY- SOME
YOU KNOW GUY- BASICALLY-
GUIDELINES- I WOULD SAY DEAL OF
PROFESSIONAL STANDARDS AROUND
THAT AND WHEN THE INSTITUTION
ITSELF SAYS NO WE CAN'T PROVIDE
IT. WE REFUSED TO PROVIDE IT-
NOT BASED ON SCIENCE BUT ON I
GUESS WE INCOME POLICY POLITICS
WHATEVER OTHER REASON. SO WHAT
IS THE SOLUTION TO THAT THEN-
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS ITS
EMERGENCY CARE AS WELL. AND SO
I GUESS THAT'S THE QUESTION IS
SO APPRECIATE THE POINTS HE
MADE  NICE AND CERTAINLY I
THINK MANY HOSPITALS. ARE OUT
THERE TO PROVIDE HIM REALLY
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITIES FOR NOT
ONLY CLINICAL TRAINING BUT ALSO
OF COURSE CLINICAL SERVICES AND
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO CANCEL
SERVICES BY GETTING SPECIALIST
FROM YOU SEE OVER THERE. AND
HAVING TRAINEES AND I HEARD
WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THE NUMBER
OF TRAINEES IN THESE HOSPITALS
AND AS SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY RAN
A TRAINING PROGRAM- YET THAT. I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS BUT
I HAVEN'T HEARD AN ANSWER THE
FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION. WHAT WHAT
IS THE ANSWER TO THIS THAN.
SURE RECOMMEND I DON'T WANNA GO
OVER ARE YOU SEE COLLEAGUES-
FIRM OKAY I CAN TELL YOU THAT
MY UNDERSTANDING AND
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SAUDIS
THAT- THAT LIMIT SOME OF THE
PROCEDURES ARE THERE ARE THERE
ARE MANY PROCEDURES THAT ARE
NOT LIMITED THAT ARE DONE AND I
DON'T I'M TALKING ABOUT. AND I
KNOW ALL THE STOP STOP STOP WE
DO WE HAVE HEARD THE- IN
OPPOSITION I JUST WANNA TALK
ABOUT THE ONES THAT BEING
FORBIDDEN. NOT BASED ON.
SCIENCE IN FACT ARE CONTRARY TO
THE PROFESSIONAL GUIDELINES
OVER OWN SPECIALTY. AGAINST
WHAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
TEACHING. ONE OF MY SUPPOSED TO
DO ABOUT THAT IT. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THAT THE
MEDICAL RESIDENTS YOU HAVE
ACCESS TO THE TYPES OF
TRAINING- THAT IS REQUIRED
UNDER THOSE RESIDENCY PROGRAM-
FISHING DAY HE SHOULD AND THEY
HAVE THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
AND EVERY CLINICAL SITE THEY
ARE LOCATED NOT JUST THAT SOME
AFTER ALL THESE ARE THE
GUIDELINES. THAT IS A TEACHER
AND CLINICAL RESIDENCY.
CORRECTIVE THIRD OF CLINICAL
RESIDENCY PROGRAM WHERE THEY'RE
REQUIRED TO UNDERSTAND AND
LEARN AS MEDICAL SPEAKER MY
UNDERSTANDING IS AND I NEEDED A
PART OF THE SEASON MAY HAVE
MORE EXPERTISE HERE. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THEY HAVE
ACCESS AND ARE TRAINED. TO DO
THE MEDICAL PROCEDURES
REQUIRED- ALL MEDICAL
PROCEDURES REQUIRED AND NOT
INCLUDE SOME OF THOSE THAT ARE
LIMITED AT THE FACILITY IN
THEIR TRAINING FOR THAT LEVEL.
OKAY AND THEN WHEN IT COMES TO
PROVIDING THOSE PROCEDURES-
THEY ARE- THERE ARE. ALL OF
THOSE FACILITIES ARE TRAINED
AND YOU KNOW TO REFER. OUT AS
WELL SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT ALL CRICKETERS ARE TRAINED
IN THOSE FACILITIES BUT THE
CARE I DON'T KNOW IF YOU ABOUT
OKAY SELINEXOR DO ANY
INTERVIEWS SEE THAT WHEN. OF
TOP FOR MOMENT OF YOU SEE
ANSWERS- AND I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE SORT OF IN A DIFFICULT
POITION BECAUSE- YOU'RE
TALKING TO SOMEONE WHO ACTUALLY
TO RUN NOT ONLY RUN A RESIDENCY
TRAINING PROGRAM BUT ALSO SAT
ON THE BOARD AND ACCREDITATION
BODY- THE ACGME THAT OVERSEES
THE QUALITY OF THE TRAINING.
AND AND NO AND SO YOU KNOW I
REALIZE YOU MAY NOT. WITH THIS
BECOMES A MAJOR PROBLEM AND- SO
EXCEEDS THE V. TURNED IT OVER
TO. A REPRESENTATIVE YOU SEE SO
WHAT ARE WE SUPPOSED TO DO IS
FACULTY. WHEN WE HAVE THE
TRAINEES AT SITES WHERE
ESSENTIALLY. TO BEING TOLD THEY
CANNOT FOLLOW THE STANDARD OF
CARE. HELLO THANK VERY MUCH DOT
CAN HEAR INPUT FROM SEE- ARE.
AND OUR TREE- OFFERING A G. B.
T. Q. INCLUSIVE. ABOARD CARE
MISS. BACK TO LIGATION IT
BETTER- ON IS SOMETHING THAT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DOES DO. YOU ARE CORRECT THAT
SOME OF THE TRAINEES ARE
IMPLICIT BUT THESE WHERE
CERTAIN SERVICES FOR POLICY BE
STREET AND- ARE IN FACT
RESTRICTED. WE DO HAVE AN
EXPECTATION. THAT ARE ATTENDING
PHYSICIAN AND OUR OUR RESIDENTS
ARE- TRAINEES. ARE OPERATING
BASED ON THEIR BEST MEDICAL
VALUES AND JUDGMENTS. THAT THEY
DON'T CHECK THEIR VALUES AT THE
DOOR AND THAT THEY'RE EXPECTED
TO YOU- PROCEED IN THAT WAY. SO
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE- WE DON'T
AGREE THAT THE FACILITIES
SHOULD HAVE THOSE KIND OF
RESTRICTIONS- BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THE UNIVERSITY AFFILIATING
IN THOSE INSTANCES WITH
HOSPITALS WHERE THEY DO HAVE
THE RESTRICTION. IS STILL
PREFERABLE- FOR PATIENTS. ARE
BEING SEEN AT THOSE FACILITIES.
YOU CAN THEN HAVE ACCESS TO
POSITION YOU ARE GUARANTEED THE
ABILITY. TO FACILITATE
REFERRALS AND TO PROVIDE
PRESCRIPTION AND TO PROVIDE
MEDICAL CONSULTATION. SO- I
HAVE THE CHALLENGING TO. YOU
AND HAS AGAIN TO SOMEONE WHO
SERVED ON THE FACULTY AND HAD
RUN A TRAINING PROGRAM AT UC-
BUT THIS IS VERY TROUBLESOME TO
ME- AND YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE
WHAT THE AUTHORS TRYING TO
TRYING TO ADDRESS- HI. I THINK
THAT I NEED TO HEAR BETTER
SOLUTIONS- THIS IS A YEAH I'VE
BEEN AT THIS IS I THINK IS
SOMEWHAT IMPERFECT SOLUTION BUT
THE PROBLEM IS THE NUMBER OF
THE- THE SOLUTION REALLY IS
THAT REQUIRING HOSPITALS TO
ALLOW PHYSICIANS. TO FOLLOW
STANDARD OF CARE NO MATTER
WHERE IT GOES. I MEAN EIGHTY
THAT REALLY S THE ULTIMATE
ANSWER THAT WE NEED TO BE
TALKING ABOUT- WHICH IS OF
COURSE YOU KNOW PRIOR PERHAPS
MORE IN THE REALM OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE IN THIS THE-
EDUCATION COMMITTEE BUT- I DO
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL IS I THINK
REFER TO THE PASSES OUT THIS
COMMITTEE REFERRED TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE. I HAPPEN TO
CHAIR THAT COMMITTEE I EXPECT
TO HEAR MORE SPECIFIC ANSWERS
ABOUT THE HEALTH ASPECTS OF
THIS BILL- BUT I DO THINK THAT
THIS BILL ADDRESSES  VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND CERTAINLY
SOMEONE WHO. IS BEEN YEAH VERY
STEEPED IN MEDICAL EDUCATION- I
CERTAINLY VERY- DOT JUST
SYMPATHETIC BUT- YOU KNOW
SHARED AUTHORS CONCERNS. AND
WELL WHAT ARE WE TEACHING OUR
OUR RESIDENTS AND MEDICAL
STUDENTS AS WELL AS WHAT KIND
OF THINGS OR WHAT KIND THAT'S A
CHOICE ANY TO THE FACULTY. THAT
YOU SEE- WHEN WE ALLOW. AN
INSTITUTION TO BASICALLY REFUSE
TO ALLOW THEM TO FOLLOW THE
STANDARD OF CARE. TO PROVIDE
THE KERRY THE QUALITY OF CARE.
THAT WE WANT THEM TO PROVIDE-
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THOSE FACULTY MEMBERS AND
RESIDENTS AND STUDENTS AT UC SO
WITH THAT- I YOU KNOW I
ATTORNEY I WANT TO SEE THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO HEALTH SO
I'M GOING TO MOVE ASKED THAT WE
MOVED TO BUILT APPROPRIATE
TIME- BUT I DEFINITELY LIKE
YOU'RE MUCH BETTER ANSWERS TO
THESE ISSUES. BEFORE THAT SHOWS
UP IN HEALTH COMMITTEE- FOR OUR
HEARING THANK YOU IS IT ****
OUT THIS COMMITTEE. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU. CENTER PAN VICE CHAU
CHOI BOGUE. I HAVE A QUESTION-
I DON'T COME FROM THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION- THE SURVEY. PERHAPS
BUT I HAVE A QUESTION. ARE
THERE ANY SPECIALIZED HOSPITALS
THAT- I TEND TO- THE ISSUES AT
HAND THAT WE'RE DISCUSSING HERE.
I CAN THINK OF IS. KOSTENLOS
THE YOU KNOW THAT SPECIALIZE IN
CANCER OR CERTAIN AREAS- DO WE
HAVE ANY SPECIALIZED HOSPITALS
THAT WE COULD WORK WITH. TO
MEET THE NEED TO WE DON'T HAVE
THE SPECIALTIES IN OTHER IN
OTHER HOSPITALS. I'M GONNA ASK
THE AUTHOR IF HE WOULD LIKE ON
THE SENATOR PANDA ANSWER THAT
OR IF HE WOULD LIKE TO ANSWER
THAT. ONE WHAT PERHAPS- THE
EXPERT OKAY. REALLY HAPPY TO
SEE I JUST YOU KNOW IT UP
THROUGH THE CHAIR BECAUSE
FUNDING FOR NOT JUST ENGAGING
DEBATE DIRECTLY. CERTAINLY
THERE ARE VARIETY DIFFERENT
HOSPITALS THAT SPECIALIZE IN
CERTAIN THINGS ARE WE HAVE
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS WITHOUT
HASSLES A CONSTRUCT CANCER WE
HAVE REHABILITATION HOSPITAL
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS AND SO
FORTH SO THERE ARE HOSPITALS.
THAT PROVIDE RIGHT BUT I ALSO
WANT TO POINT OUT FOR EXAMPLE
JUST BECAUSE YOU HAVE CANCER
YOU MEDIA HOSPITAL SPECIALIZES
IN CANCER DOESN'T MEAN ALL THE
OTHER HEALTH PROBLEMS GO AWAY.
SO OFTEN TIMES WELL THE
HOSPITAL MAY FOCUS ON
PARTICULAR ASPECTS. OFTENTIMES
THE HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ARE
PROVIDING SOME OTHER FORMS OF
CAREAS WELL BECAUSE FAMILY IN
PSYCHIATRIC HOSPITALS WHILE
THEY TRY TO BE SURE YOU GOT ALL
YOUR MEDICAL ISSUES SETTLED THE
HUNTER NOT YOU KNOW NOT
EVERYTHING IS. AS IT GOES AWAY
WITH THAT HAS A CURE RIGHT AWAY
SO- THERE IT DOESBLEED OVER
INTO AGENCY THERE'S CARE FOR
OTHER TYPES OF HEALTH ISSUES.
AT EVEN THE SPECIALIZED
HOSPITALS. VENTURA CAN- PLEASE
FOR THAT OCCURRED HERE- AND I
THINK. OUR GO TO PAN PUT IT
REALLY WELL IN AND TO BE MORE.
ON BECAUSE THE USE. AND THE
HOUSE ASSOCIATION POINT ITSELF.
AFFILIATION WHERE YOU SEE THE
OR CANCER SPECIAL SERVICE INTO
A OF THE TOP. YES TREATING FOR
CANCER- BUT THE CANCER PATIENT
MIGHT BE A WOMAN PREGNANT- AND
SO THAT REDUCES OWN MEDICAL
ISSUES THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE CANCER
SPECIALIST. YOU KNOW THAT THEY
CAN PROVIDE FOR CARE FOR THE
CANCER PATIENT MIGHT BE TRANS
AND THERE MIGHT BE ISSUES ABOUT
HOW DO WE DO WE NEED TO ADJUST
ANY HORMONES OR TAKE THAT INTO
ACCOUNT. AND SO WHEN WE HAVETHESE THESE NON SCIENCE BASED
RESTRICTIONS THAT CONTRADICTS.
THE STANDARD OF CARE. YOU END
UP HAVING PATIENTS THAT THEIR
HEALTHCARE IS UNDERMINED EVEN
UPON THE SERVICE REALLY WILL
TELL ME CANCER NO GOES MUCH
DEEPER THAN THAT SO IT'S IT
REALLY IS BROADER- THAN ONE
pWOULD THINK IN TERMS OF THIS
PROBLEM. THANK YOU CENTER. FOR
TROUBLED TO HEAR FURTHER FOLLOW
UP I DO I DO HAVE A STATEMENT
THAT I'D LIKE TO MAKE- WITH
REGARDS TO MY TO MY AREA AND- I
AM VERY SYMPATHETIC. TO THE
CONCERNS AND I THINK I'M GONNA
TAKE IT FROM AN ANGLE OF. THE
SHORT IS A SHORT SHORTAGE OF
DOCTORS THAT WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA AS A WHOLE AND THEM
SPECIALLY IN MY REGION. I HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH HOW
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY FIVE
WILL AFFECT MY DISTRICT- THE
INLAND EMPIRE. HAS LONG
SUFFERED FROM A SHORTAGE OF
PHYSICIANS COMPARED TO OTHER
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA. ACCORDING
TO CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FOUNDATION THE REGION ONLY HAS
ONLY THIRTY FIVE PRIMARY CARE
PHYSICIANS PER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE. LET ME REPEAT
THAT AGAIN. THIRTY FIVE PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS PER ONE HUNDRED
PEOPLE. COMPARED TO SEVENTY OR
MORE IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE. THAT SHORTAGE IS ONE OF
THE REASONS THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA OPENED ITS NEWEST
MEDICAL SCHOOL THERE. ALONG
WITH A MODEL THAT RELIES ON
COMMUNITY HOSPITALS AS A PLACE
FOR TRAINING. IN PATIENT CARE
RATHER THAN OWNING OR OPERATING
ITS OWN HOSPITALS AS IS THE
CASE I. UC'S OTHER HELP
CAMPUSES. UCR SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE WHICH WERE VERY PROUD
OF. IS ENTIRELY RELIANT AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
HOSPITALS AND FACILITIES IN THE
REGION TO TRAIN OUR MEDICAL
STUDENTS AND SUPPORT A
RESIDENCY AND FELLOWSHIP
TRAINING PROGRAMS. YOU SEE ARE
DEVELOPED A BROAD ARRAY OF
EDUCATIONAL AFFILIATION
AGREEMENTS WITH COUNTY PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT AND PRIVATE NON. FOR
PROFIT HOSPITALS ACROSS THE
REGION NO SINGLE HOSPITAL
PROVIDES THE ENTIRE TRAINING
EXPERIENCE FOR ALL OUR STUDENTS
AND TRAINEES. YOU SEE OUR HAS
BUILT SUCCESSFUL MEDICAL
PIPELINE PROGRAMS WITH REGIONAL
K. TWELVE AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND HAS EXECUTED
IMPACTFUL COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS SUCH AS STREET
MEDICINE SERVING MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE. AND ON HEALTH
RESIDENTS AND CO HOSTED COVE IN
NINETEEN CLINICS SERVING
FARMWORKERS. ALL OF THESE
PROGRAMS ARE RELIANT ON MEDICAL
STUDENTS AND RESIDENTS. SEVERAL
OF THESEAFFILIATIONS SUCH AS
THOSE WITH DIGNITY ST
BERNARDINE MEDICAL CENTER AND
LOMA LINDA MEDICAL CENTER BOTH
HOSPITALS OF WHICH HAVE SERVED
MY FAMILY AND FRIENDS. WOULD BE
PROHIBITED IF S. B. THREE SEVEN
NINE FOUR TWO PASSED IN ITS
CURRENT FORM. SEVERELY LIMITING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FUTURE
POSITIONS TO FULFILL MANDATORY
EXPERIENCE REQUIREMENTS. WITH
SB THREE SEVENTY NINE ALL OF
YOU SEE OUR SCHOOL OF MEDICINE
SPONSORED RESIDENCY AND
FELLOWSHIP TRAINING PROGRAMS
EXCEPT PSYCHIATRY WILL BE
ELIMINATED. WITHOUT A PRIMARY
AFFILIATE HOSPITAL YOU SEE OUR
WILL LOSE ACCREDITATION FOR
THESE PROGRAMS AND WE'LL NEED
TO CLOSE THEM. THIS BILL ALSO
CALLS INTO QUESTION THE FUTURE
OF YOU SEE OUR COMMUNITY BASED
MEDICAL SCHOOL. ELIMINATIONOF
PARTNERS SUCH AS THESE WOULD
MAKE THE COMMUNITY BASED MODEL
DIFFICULT TO SUSTAIN. LASTLY
WITH THE ELIMINATION OF THE
SEVENTY FOUR SLOTS MORE YOU SEE
OUR GRADUATES WILL NEED TO
LEAVE THE AREA FOR TRAINING AND
WILL BE LESS LIKELY TO RETURN
SOMETHING THAT IS MUCH MUCH
NEEDED IN MY REGION. YOU SEE
ARE WILL LOSE THE CAPACITY TO
ATTRACT MEDICAL STUDENTS FROM
OTHER SCHOOLS TO OUR REGION FOR
TRAINING. ERASING THE PROGRESS
WE HAVE MADE IN ADDRESSING THE
PRIMARY CARE PHYSICIAN SHORTAGE
IN THAT REGION. THIS WILL LEAVE
MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS WITHOUT
TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE. ALREADY
A MUCH DIFFICULT- THING TO
ADDRESS I CANNOT SUPPORT A BILL
AT THIS TIME THAT WOULD
DEVASTATE MY REGION AND THE
HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
TURBOBIT NEXT SENATOR DOLLY AND
THEN SENATOR GLAZERS HUNDRED
DOLLARS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
APPRECIATE YOU GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK I WANTED
JUST TO GO ON RECORD I'M
OPPOSING THIS BILL- I WANTED TO
SHARE. A LITTLE SOME THOUGHTS-
THE GURNEY EDUCATION COMMITTEE
THIS IS ABOUT CAN WE TREAT CAN
WE TRAIN. THIS I BELIEVE THAT'S
WHY IT'S HERE CAN WE TRAIN
THESE DOCTORS. AND CLINICIANS
IN A WAY THAT THEY CAN GET THE
TRAINING THEY NEED- THE NEXT
COMMITTEE I BELIEVE. SO FOR ME
IS I'M I'M ASSUMING I WAS GONNA
SURE HOW THIS IS GOING TO PACK
MY DISTRICT I HAVE MERCY
DIGNITY BOTH OF MY DISTRICT.
AND MANY OF YOU KNOW. THAT I
COME FROM BEAVER BUDGET DON'T
KNOW BEAVERS. ITS IT'S A
HUNDRED TWENTY MY FROM REDDING
CALIFORNIA WHERE WE HAVE
DIGNITY AND MERCY WE HAVE A
SMALL HOSPITAL- A DISTRICT
HOSPITAL ACTUALLY MIRRORS WHERE
MY CHILDREN WERE BORN- THEY
DON'T GIVE THAT SERVICE ANYMORE-
AND IF EVEN AS FAR. NORTH OF ME
WHICH IS ALMOST TO THE OREGON
BORDER IN NEVADA BORDER THERE
ARE NO HOSPITALS THAT DELIVER
BABIES SO PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY
RIGHT NOW TRAVELING. A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILES TO HAVE A CHILD.
TODAY. IF THIS BILL IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE IT LOOK THIS IS ABOUT
CONTRACTING THIS IS ABOUT.
HOSPITALS THAT HAVE BELIEVES
THAT THEY DON'T WANT TO PROVIDE
CERTAIN SERVICES THAT'S WHERE
THIS IS REALLY HAD. IF THESE IF
THIS BILL WAS SIGNED INTO LAW
AND- THOSE HOSPITALS SHE CHOSE
NOT TO CONTRACT WITH THE UC'S.
WE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN THOSE
BOTTLES WERE NOT THERE WE WOULD
NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO DELIVER
A BABY. FOR THE IMPACT OF THIS
BILL GO VERY WIDE INDEED. AND
THERE'S ALSO A PHILOSOPHICAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT IT SO. FOR
THOSE REASONS AND WHAT THE WITH
WHAT THE HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION-
THE- MENTIONED I WILL BE
OPPOSING THE BILL TODAY I'M
HOPEFUL. THAT THERE CAN BE SOME
NEGOTIATIONS WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY. GET THE TRAINING AND
GET THE ERVICES THAT THOSE
PEOPLE WANT IN OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT'S WHERE I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THIS GO- BECAUSE WE THERE'S
A LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE THAT MAY
BE IMPACTED. INDIRECTLY BY THIS
ONE ACTION SO I JUST WANT TO
GET THAT ON THE RECORD. I WANT
TO SET UP I HAVE TO LEAVE YOUR
A LITTLE BIT AFTER ACTUALLY
BROKE A TOOTH AND I NEED TO GET
IT FIXED AND I'M HOPING THAT I
GET TO STAY TO VOTE AND- HAVE
POST NAVIGATION THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. THANK YOU CENTER CALLING
CENTER GLAZER. THANK YOU MAY
CHAIR AND- AND MA'AM. AT FIRST
I WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT I
STRONGLY REPRODUCTIVE- AND
GENDER AFFIRMING SERVICES- I
ALSO DON'T SUPPORT RESTRICTIONS
ON MEDICAL CARE- FOR WOMEN FOR
TRANSGENDER- IN ANY IN ANY WAY
SHAPE OR FORM- AND I DON'T
SUPPORT LIMITATIONS ON IN THE
PRACTICING OF MEDICAL CARE AT
THE HIGHEST QUALITY LEVEL. BUT
THERE ARE A COUPLE ISSUES WITH
THIS BILL THAT HAVE RAISED SOME
CONCERNS WITH ME- AT THE AUTHOR
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE HIS
THOUGHTS ON THAT- I WOULD
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE IT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM IT. ON THE FIRST
ISSUE IS THAT IS THE MATTER OF
THE ECONOMY AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA. IT WILL BE
POLITICS SWIRL AROUND THIS
PLACE AND HAVE FOR MORE THAN A
HUNDRED YEARS. AND WE HAVE IN
THE WISDOM OF OUR FOUNDERS AND
OUR CURRENT. AND THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE GIVEN A LEVEL
OF A TIME TO MEET THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
HOW THEY DO THEIR WORK. AS WE
DON'T WANT POLITICS DRIVING.
THE ACADEMIC DECISIONS- AND TO
SOME LEVEL WE'VE DONE THE SAME
WITH THIS THIS THE- THE OTHER
FOR YOUR SYSTEM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. AND THE GOAL
THERE IS TO ENSURE THAT- THE
POLITICAL WINDS OF THE MOMENT.
I DON'T INTERFERE WITH THEIR
THOUGHTFUL- GOVERNANCE OF THE
UNIVERSITY. AND SO IT I
UNDERSTAND THE AUTHORS
INDICATED THAT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA HAS AS BEEN.
HASN'T HAD A TASK FORCE ON THIS
MATTER IS TAKING THE ISSUE
SERIOUSLY- WAS PREPARED TO
DELIBERATE AND TAKE SOME ACTION
ON IT THIS PAST YEAR BUT
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC QUITE
UNDERSTANDABLY- THE MATTER GOT
PUT TO THE SIDE BUT THEY HAVE.
COMMITTED TO HAVING THAT
THOUGHTFUL DELIBERATIONS. AMONG
THE BOARD OF REGENTS- AT AND I
GUESS WHAT'S TROUBLING TO ME IS
THAT WHY WE WOULD GIVEN THE
CHANCE TO ACT- THAT- YEAH WE
CAN REVIEW THEIR ACTIONS AND
DECIDE WHETHER WE THINK THEY'RE
GOOD OR BAD AND DECIDE WHETHER
WE WANT TO BREAK DOWN THAT WALL
OF- PROTECTION THAT'S BEEN IN
PLACE FOR A LONG TIME. AND- YOU
KNOW IT. FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
KNOWN ME AND THAT THE THINGS
THAT I HAVE SPOKEN ABOUT THIS
ISSUE OF A TANAMI GOES WAY
BEYOND THIS ISSUE AND WE HAVE
HAD OTHER BILLS THAT HAVE COME
BEFORE THE SENATE. THAT HAVE
FIVE RAISE THE SAME CONCERNS
AND QUESTIONS THAT I'VE
DECLINED TO SUPPORT FOR THOSE
REASONS. SO I AM- CONCERN THAT
THAT WE'RE ACTING PREMATURELY-
AND THAT WE HAVEN'T REALLY
GIVEN THEM THE CHANCE TO- TO
MAKE CHOICES AND BY THE WAY.
THAT WE DO HAVE AN ABILITY TO
INFLUENCE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND OUR RULES OF THE
SENATE WE CONFIRM EVERY REGION
APPOINTEE BY THE GOVERNOR. AND
I I'D BE INTERESTED IN KNOWING
WHETHER THE REGION APPOINTEES
THAT WE'VE CONFIRMED OVER THE
LAST FEW YEARS HAVE BEEN ASKED
THESE QUESTIONS SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT THIS TYPE OF AN ISSUE.
BECAUSE THAT'S THE APPROPRIATE
PLACE FOR US TO HAVEINPUT.
INTO THEIR WORK IS TO ENSURE
THAT THE APPOINTEES THE
REGION'S DECISION MAKERS. KERRY
FORTH OUR VALUES- AND THE
VALUES THAT ARE EXPRESSED IN
THIS BILL- WHICH I SUPPORT-
THE- SECOND ISSUE WHICH- HAS
PARTLY BEEN RAISED BY THE
SENATOR FROM YUCAIPA- IS THIS
QUESTION OF THAT MANY OF THESE
CONTRACTS ARE NARROWLY-
FOCUSED. IN AREAS THAT DON'T
TOUCH. MEDICAL CARE FOR WOMEN
OR TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS- NOW
THE AUTHOR MADE RAP REFERENCE
TO CANCER CENTER WE I GUESS THE
UC PARTNERS TO. MANAGE A CANCER
CENTER AND THERE COULD BE
ISSUES THAT CROSS OVER- AND
RAISE QUESTIONS- BUT WE ALSO.
AT TWO TWENTY YEAR CAL ALSO.
RADIATION ONCOLOGY TREATMENT-
NEONATAL SERVICES AND SO IT
CERTAINLY SEEMS THAT THERE IS.
A BREATH OF THESE CONTRACTS
THAT GO WAY BEYOND- THE
POTENTIAL TO UNDERMINE. THE
TYPE OF- THE SUPPORT THAT WE
ALL THAT MANY OF US FEEL-
IMPORTANT- IN THE AREA OF
REPRODUCTIVE AND GENDER
AFFIRMING A SERVICES. FINALLY I
A- WHAT IS IN THE JURISDICTION
OF THIS COMMITTEE IS THE ISSUE
OF CLINICAL REQUIREMENTS. AND
RESIDENCY OPPORTUNITIES AND I
DO KNOW. THAT FOR IN MANY
FIELDS THERE ARE NOT SUFFICIENT.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR TUDENTS
TO HAVE THOSE CLINICAL
REQUIREMENTS BE MET AND WE HAVE
DEBATED IN VARIOUS COMMITTEES
AT THE SENATE AND ON THE FLOOR
THE SENATE HOW THAT IS LIMITING.
ACCESS TO CARE BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE TRAINED PERSONNEL WHO
HAD GIVEN GET THEN PROVIDED
WITH THOSE CLINICAL
OPPORTUNITIES I WOULD BE ALSO
INTERESTED IN HEARING- WHAT.
EFFORTS CAN BE MADE OR SHOULD
BE MADE TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
ARE RESTRICTED GIVEN THE
STAFFING LIMITATIONS WHICH A
BIG KNOWLEDGE EARLIER IN
DISCUSSIONS IN THIS COMMITTEE.
FINALLY I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS INCREDIBLE
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA. WE
SHARE THE SAME VALUES. AS BEEN
EXPRESSED AS BUT PURPOSES OF
THIS BILL AND HE'S BEEN A TRUE
CHAMPION- FOR THOSE VALUES AND
I KNOW THIS BILL REFLECTS. HIS
AT BEST OF INTENTIONS TO TRY TO
ADVANCE THE GOOD THAT WE ALL
WANT TO SEE IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND OUR STATE. I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THE BILL MOVING FORWARD
TODAY BUT I HOPE THAT. THESE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE BEEN RATE
I HAVE REYES WILL. STIMULATE
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS AND THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE WHERE IT'S
GOING NEXT. AND THAT
CONSIDERATION- IF A BILL REALLY
AS NECESSARY AND AS I SAID THE-
PERSON THAT THAT BREAKING DOWN
THE AUTONOMY OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA'S NOT SOMETHING I
DO VERY EASILY. BUT IF THE BILL
WAS TO ADVANCE I HOPE THAT IT
WOULD BE BE NARROWED TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT- PLACES IN WHICH-
THESE PARTNERSHIPS DON'T
INTERFERE WITH THESE VALUES
THAT THIS BILL TRIES TO
PROTECT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER. SENATOR WIENER I
HAVE NO OTHER QUESTIONS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS SENATOR
GLAZERS CONCERNS IN YOUR
CLOTHES. HAPPY TWO TERRIFIC.
FOR ME IT IS A MICROPHONE OR
AND YET I HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
CUBA SO PLAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
CLOTHES. ANSWERING ANY OF
SENATOR GLAZERS QUESTIONS ARM
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH I DO
JUST WANT TO KNOW IN TERMS OF-
CENTER DOLLIES- ARE COMMON AND
YOU KNOW IF WE KNOW ARE PARTS
OF THE STATE WHERE THERE
CHALLENGES. BUT I ALSO THINK IT
TERMS OF ARE DOLLARS RAISES- WE
ALSO NEED TO KEEP MIND THE RYE
NOW. IF YOU ARE BEING BY YOU
SEE IF AND NOT PART OF THE
STATE AND YOU NEED TO ARE YOU
DID OR YOU NEED A AVOID. OF OR
YOU NEED TO HURRICANE- YOU HAVE
TRAVEL ON OF MILES TENS.
TOGETHER BECAUSE OF THE
RESEARCH SO ARE BEING IN THE
WAY- LAW OF THE WAYS AND WE'RE
TO ADDRESS AND BILL AND- ONE
BECAUSE- WE'RE NOT SAYING DON'T
HAVE A PHILLY OR. POLLUTION
AGREEMENTS CAN BE EXTRA.
VALUABLE FOR THE U. OR FOR
OTHERS. BUT THOSE A POLICE
AGREE. NEED TO BE NOT TO
CONSIST CAL. NEW SEE VALLEY.
BUT NEW TO AVOID OUT FOR. P.
AND- CHARACTER DO A FILM. THE
SAKE. THAT THE HAAS SERVICES
TALKING THIS IS THIS SKIES FALL.
AND MEDICAL. WERE GET TREAT WE
THINK THAT A VERY EXOTIC. GIVEN
THE- SCALE. VISITATION FOR
RIGHT NOW. CARE FOR LOW INCOME
HAS BEEN UNDER MY- WHEN THEY
ARE. FOR GETTING CARE ME USED.
BOB IS A- I'M IN TERMS OF AND
IT AT THE YOU FOR THE AWFUL- WE
BE CLEAR THIS IS NOT AN ISSUE.
POP UP. AND WE BROWN AND AN
OUNCE A BILL. THIS IS BEEN
GOING FOR YEAR AND YEARS AND
HAS BEEN A BALL. IN THE WORKING
GROUP OF CONVENE. AGO BY PRESS
OF ALL- TO TRY TO. AS AND YEARS
LATER- IT HASN'T BEEN RESULT
USE DID QUITE A- MISTER PARTY
MEN. PROVISIONS AND YOU CAN'T
HAVE A JOB ORDER ON YOU SEE
POSITION WHERE THEY CAN. THEY
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO HELP SENDS.
YOU BENEFIT FROM THIS OF TO- I
CAN REFER YOU. TO A HOT. DOWN
THE ROAD OR A HUNDRED MILE AWAY.
I CAN GIVE YOU A RISK.
AFFILIATION THERE'S A LOT OF
OPPOSITION TO IT AND THEY
DEFERRED THIS IS SEVERAL YEARS
AGO SINCE BEEN GOING ON FOR A
LONG TIME AND HAS NOT GOTTEN
RESULTS- AS MR FLAHERTY
MENTIONED I'VE BEEN MEETING
REGULARLY. WITH PRESIDENT THREE
OUR COALITION HAS BEEN MEETING
WITH SENIOR YOU SEE MANAGEMENT.
WE WOULD LOVE FOR THE REGION'S
TO RESOLVE THIS. THAT WOULD BE
EXCELLENT IF THE REGION'S
RESOLVED AS AN APPROPRIATE WITH
SATISFACTORY WAY. THAT'S WHAT
WE WANT BUT IT HAS NOT HAPPENED
AND WE HAVE NOT GOTTEN ANY.
INDICATION TO OUR SATISFACTION
THAT IT WILL HAPPEN- AND SO
THAT'S WHY WE INTRODUCED THE
BILL WAS NOT. OPTION ONE.
OPTION TWO. PICTURES THE BILL
WE THOUGHT THAT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO DO SO. I'M IN
TERMS OF SPECIALTIES- AND
MENTIONED THAT ERLIER IT'S
HOLISTIC AND EVEN IF IT IS A
SPECIALIZED SETTING. THESE
ISSUES CAN ABSOLUTELY COME UP
AND THEN A POSITION AS. A
PARENT PROVIDING A TREATMENT-
IN TERMS OF RESIDENT. I THINK
THE PAST DRESSER REALLY- AGAIN
WHEN I TRYING TO IF ONLY. BUT
WE WANT TO RESIDENTS TO
ACTUALLY GET THE FULL TRAINING.
AND THERE'S ACTUALLY A SLEW OF
STUDIES FOR HAPPY TO PROVIDE.
THAT RESIDENTS. RECEIVE
TRAINING AND IS RESTRICTED
SETTINGS. ACTUALLY END UP NOT
KNOWING HOW TO DO THOSE
PROCEDURES I MEAN LIKE PEER
REVIEWED STUDIES. THAT POSITION
TO AFFECT I'M NOT I DON'T I'M
NOT COMFORTABLE. PUTTING IN ARE
YOU DE AND A WOMAN BECAUSE I
NEVER GOT THE REAL TRAINING. TO
DO THAT AND THAT IS NOT WHAT WE
WANT YOU SEE RESIDENTS TO COME
OUT HAVING HAD THEIR EDUCATION.
BY IMPAIRED- YOU KNOW I THINK
ANY OF THOSE A LOT OF- I THINK
EXAGGERATED STATEMENTS FROM THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT WHAT THE
IMPACT OF THIS BILL WILL BE.
GIVEN A VERY TINY PERCENTAGE.
OF YOU SEE TERRORISTS CURRENTLY
PROVIDED IN THIS CONTEXT. BUT
IT WILL GROW OVER TIME WE KNOW
THAT YOU SEE WANTS TO GROW
SIGNIFICANTLY. BUT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT AS HIS
AFFILIATIONS GROW. THAT WE
ACTUALLY PUT THE RULES IN PLACE
I MEAN EXPECTATIONS. AND THE
FOUNDATION IN PLACE RIGHT NOW
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE IN TEN YEARS.
WHOEVER SUCCEEDS ME IN THE
SENATE. ALABI TURNED OUT BY
THEN- WE WILL HAVE TO COME BACK
AND THEN ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
WORD. 30% OF YOU SEE CARE IS
BEING PROVIDED INSTALLATIONS WE
WANT TO FIX IT NOW. DR WE HAVE
INTRODUCED THIS BILL- I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SAN WIENER. THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM EIGHT SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH LEYVA FONG LEYVA HI
OTOBO NO ACTUAL NO PROTESTS
EIGHT FIVE CORTES HI KELLY NO
SELLING NO GLAZER HI GLAZER HI
MCGUIRE HI REQUIRED BY. HAND BY
HAND HI. THE BILLS L. YOU VERY
MUCH NOW WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
THE ROLE ON THE BILLS THAT WERE
ON CALL WE WILL START WITH SB
THREE SIXTY SEVEN OF HER TADO
MEN CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB THREE SIXTY SEVEN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON HEALTH.
CARE VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTING AYE. MCGUIRE HI REQUIRED
BY. THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON
THE SP SEVENTY RUBIO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
SIX SB SEVENTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE
HI. THE BILL IS L. FIVE TWO TWO
FIVE THE NEXT BILL IS. SB FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT RUBIO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM SEVEN
SB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING ON
A VICE CHAIR VOTING I'D MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE ON THE BILLS OUT SEVEN
ZERO. MIXED IN WITH THREE
SEVENTY NINE I THINK WE ARE
GOOD SO- THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE CALL THE MISSING MEMBERS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CONSENT AGENDA VOTING I BY SURE
VOTING AYE MCGUIRE AYE MCGUIRE
AYE THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
APPROVED SEVEN ZERO MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION TODAY THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY. IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE THANK YOU WE WANT
YOU TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN OUR OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD.
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
CORPORATIONS CORPORATION WE
HAVE CONCLUDED OUR AGENDA I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK MADAM
MODERATOR FOR HELPING US GET
THROUGH THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION IS ADJOURNED.